There's no season 10 was the best.
Here we go.
We're to live.
Don't say anything.
Don't say anything,
right.
Welcome to fight companion.
If you never heard one of these podcasts before,
this is not a normal podcast,
but sometimes it becomes a normal podcast.
So take a chance,
bitch.
Brendan shops in the motherfucking house and my brother Eddie Bravo,
and of course,
and we're watching the fights.
This is fight night live from Japan.
It's um,
Josh Barnett versus big country.
Roy Nelson.
That's the main event.
Uriah hall versus Musashi.
That's a fight I really want to say that's tonight too.
That's a big fucking fight.
That's a juicy one.
It's a big one,
a huge one for you.
And it's a big chance for Moose saucy when he has to take a chance.
Musafa.
He's given them a shot.
I think if you're Ryan Hall shows up.
That's Uriah Hall is best moments inside the octagon.
Like Uriah Hall,
I think when he's sharp is one of the fastest fucking one.
One,
185 pounds.
He's a monster.
He's so athletic.
You know what wouldn't take one of them the most?
To me,
the biggest curiosities about that dude's when he broke his foot,
fucked it up real bad.
Like you could look down in between rounds.
We're looking at his toe.
His Toe was Jack.
The bone was sticking out of it.
Hobbles back to his corner.
Then the bell starts the next round.
He's throwing kicks with it.
He's throwing kicks with it and he's moving around like he doesn't feel fucking
thing.
And then as soon as the rounds over that mean that he's wobbling,
it'd be barely walk at the end of the fight.
That takes some serious mental toughness for sure.
Which is your eyes biggest knock,
right?
His mental.
Exactly.
I trained with the guy for a year.
What do you think?
He's a athletically.
He's the biggest freak.
He's his own worst enemy.
If,
if the.
If the.
If the hall shows up with the right mind frame.
Yeah man,
he's.
He's one of the best in the world.
That's a big fucking f.
and guess what?
Moussaka is five guys,
just like you're at home.
He's beat Osp.
Hector,
Lumbar,
back in the day holding flat,
big disclosive bank Osp has mad potential,
don't get me wrong,
and I think he gets better every time he fights.
Like the shogun knockout was a big fucking deal.
I was super shocked by that.
The Pack Cummins knock on.
I was like,
whoa.
OSP is getting better every single time we see him,
but like it would come to the execution of techniques.
There's just some shit that uriah hall can do that Osp can't quite do.
I didn't see,
but those will be shielded off against world class competition.
Hasn't beat any ebo right?
No.
You're hunting kind of c level guys.
You're 100 percent.
Right.
And that was my,
my kind of original point was that Uriah Hall,
like his movement inside the octagon,
like when he's sharp as he can be,
he can do some freaky shit.
One hundred percent.
He can.
You see that Ron stallings fight when you get that right hand,
right hand is a God damn late Matrix Shit Matrix shift,
right?
It's just a matter of stringing together those moments when it's crucial and OSP
has definitely been able to do that more than him.
Yes,
100 percent,
but when it becomes too like those spectacular movements that Uriah Hall dues,
when I see Osp,
I see a super strong,
really tough guy who obviously works real hard and is better every time you see
him fight,
right?
Like those fucking power left kicks.
He throws a crazy athlete and he's.
He's got total world championship potential.
If that guy keeps accelerating at the pace he's at now you can see Osp at a
world championship level in a year,
maybe even two years.
True.
One hundred percent,
but what you're Ryan Hall does,
he does that every now and then.
You get these bursts of that next level shit.
You get these bursts of that.
Ron stallings,
righthand the we'll kick that.
He knocked that kid out on tough and again,
he's not fighting this the highest level of competition when he's pulling these
techniques off,
but they're there for.
They're there but not,
but he just hasn't done it.
Like you said,
against a high level guy.
Then when he started pulling that shit like people that shit off tonight against
them saucy,
like most aussies kind of seen this man.
He's like,
he's made some good good.
Certainly.
It certainly has with Musashi.
He just.
I don't know what it is.
He just fucking good tight muscles in his mind,
Bro.
Is it 10th planet now your aisle?
P O.
S.
P is
at double or nothing.
I own a thousand from the last fight and a running tab.
Definitely better this way.
Nobody ever asked to really like get hurt and pay someone $10,000.
200,000 dollars.
You got to suck his dick for $100,000.
Thousand Dollars.
If you would just clear clean my bed out.
I'm not saying I would do it,
but you would have to sit down with your friends.
Have to talk to my wife about it.
I have to imagine how gay Brenda would have to be to let you this check for 100
grand
just to get the pictures to suck his dick.
He wouldn't do it for,
for being gay.
He would do it to get the fucking pictures.
Man,
you would have those pictures are already out there,
but you'd be open to it
if anybody knows how to suck your Dick.
Right.
It's a girl photo.
Photoshop your face,
Joe.
Like really,
really good on some dude blowing another dude.
Oh for sure.
The golden rule.
The Internet.
If there's a picture of you out there,
someone somewhere has photoshop with Dick in your mouth.
Otherwise you ain't doing shit on my own website of and my website.
Nice.
This dude named [inaudible] from England,
but we did 100 floppy,
hilarious.
Who had the most hilarious.
Oh
my God.
And it was me.
They always involve like 100 black dicks.
I could have 50 arms and shit is ridiculous.
They're funny.
His helmet,
his,
his.
He's always done.
It was like a funny sense of humor,
but some people can do it and they can get so close that girls get really mad
because like famous actresses have been like in porn scenes,
they just put their body in,
you know,
they more for girls.
So good.
You can do anything now with that stuff.
With photo editing,
they can literally have you wrestling a dinosaur.
All their needs.
You're faced anything from game of thrones.
When they made her walk through the city naked,
turns out it wasn't her body.
Right.
Wow.
Is that true?
Is the body.
That's what Red Band set?
I don't know if that's true.
Well,
he would probably know.
I think it is true.
I mean it makes sense to watch that shit.
Was that chick I was probably be like,
look,
you can make a dragon.
You can't give me fake tits.
I agree.
Why do you have to see my real teeth?
That's creepy.
I don't want you to stare into my asshole.
I walked on the street.
She was totally naked and you got like a hundred,
200 people that are working as extras that are the slaves and the peasants
people.
So they're all going to see her naked too.
That's not fun.
Yeah.
You see her ass all and she's like,
bear crawling through the city.
I've been naked in a couple of things.
I was naked in this,
uh,
thing that I did for a news radio once.
I had to be naked in front of the whole idea was like I was waiting for this
chick in her apartment and uh,
uh,
I was trying to,
I forget the whole premise.
I guess I was trying to get her to date me or something like that.
So I lit a bunch of candles.
I took my clothes off.
Do they pay extra for that or no?
I don't.
No,
I think so.
Do you have something over your junk and no knowledge of my Dick was hanging out
and when she came in I covered it up.
I had to cover it up.
Like that was the scene of the movie.
Like,
Whoa,
it's you or I forget the premise.
It was on news radio was long time ago.
It was not uncomfortable for sure.
Yeah.
And then there was another one that I did for the vh one fashion awards.
It was like 1997.
I did this thing where I played this photographer that was crazy and he,
I didn't know anything about photography.
I was just to try to get laid.
That was the whole thing.
And uh,
I would say to the girl,
do you have any problems with nudity?
And she goes,
no,
and next thing you know,
I'm taking pictures of her while naked.
So I had to be naked in front of her.
That was European.
She didn't get back in the day.
Back in the day,
dude,
I was seven.
I was in line behind Tony to suits.
I remember that guy.
That guy's a wild man for from Peru,
Brazilian Jujitsu and a neck tie.
He didn't exactly.
He did a 2003 Abu Dhabi.
And when we were weighing in,
I killed myself to get down to 1:45 and I'm in line and he's in front of me and
we both got our underwear on.
And you see the Japanese press right there.
You see Brazilian press holy,
the Gracie sitting down where I'm waiting to weigh in.
Tony goes first,
he drops his under what gets naked.
No one says shit.
He gets naked,
he weighs any makes way.
And then I come in and I was so close I got,
I guess it's cool to get naked.
I pulled down
and the Japanese press come up quick and start taking pictures of your Dick,
me naked,
standing there naked.
So I started doing comfortable poses and like most
of most muscular poses,
one post I then I went like this,
you know.
Then I did the opposite of the incredible hulk and I got all a submissive and
just covered my balls.
Like I was really shy and it got.
That's the picture they use.
They put that Shit on magazine.
I'm like,
Joe,
is there anything that could pay you now to do that?
To get naked and film some shit on TV?
I just thought he just passed.
It's not that big a deal.
Like what?
What's the big deal?
You're someone sees your Dick people that were so crazy about your body.
But if someone was like,
oh Joe went on TV music awards and wants you to be on stage.
No,
I don't think that would be something I'd be into doing and pass the seems very
embarrassing.
But the idea behind it is that there's something wrong with you being naked,
you know,
and like that.
We don't know that we all.
I mean,
look at this crowd of people,
right?
You Watch these two dudes fight.
We don't even know who they are.
You Watch these two.
Does a good scrap actually had his humbly just got dropped.
Look at all those people in the audience and you'll notice they all have clothes
on.
I mean,
it's kind of ridiculous.
Clothes are kind of ridiculous.
You just want everyone to be naked.
No,
but this,
this idea that we've created this outer wear,
like some sort of a fucking weird homemade hermit crab thing.
We've created this outer shell that we must have on except in the most intimate
moments.
I mean there's something almost.
There's almost something where the human race realized how sexual and fucking
crazy it is and like,
look,
the only way we're going to get anything done is if we invent close cover shit
up.
We just can't have people just fucking.
Every time they run into each other,
first husband just cover up their checks or make that makes sense.
Well,
if you look at the oldest civilizations on earth,
it's the Middle East,
right?
And aren't those the ones who cover the women up the most?
I
ever have to deal with jealousy or possessiveness.
Mad Genius.
Like $50,
billion dollars,
you know,
that's the least they could do.
You don't know what you're getting though.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like a cracker Jack.
There was like a loyalty guy that was arrested in La for sexual assault.
Some woman came screaming out of his place.
She was like half naked or something like that.
Really?
That he was arrested and he,
he doesn't have immunity and it's a one of a series of events that have happened
with like really rich people from the Middle East in Beverly Hills over the last
couple of weeks.
Because the other one that happened was there was a race.
I don't know if I talked about it with you now with me.
We went to,
we went to Disneyland.
They have this thing called Saudi summer and in the summer in Saudi Arabia,
it's apparently it's unfucking God the hot.
So a lot of people come over from Saudi Arabia to la and they buy these crazy
powerhouses in beverly hills.
And they bring over these cars that he's multimillion dollar cars,
like a blue gotti.
They run like a one and a half million dollar and they have
Arab license plates on them.
They don't even have like,
it's not even a registered car in America that could.
They bring them over here in.
They're allowed to drive them around.
And so they're driving these cars around and they're racing through the streets
of Beverly Hills and they get video of it.
People get video of these people in million dollar cars running red lights.
This guy in a porsche gt,
three is chasing them,
runs a red light or runs a stop sign.
It's fucking crazy to watch.
So there's wild and out out.
These people are at,
there's other people at the intersection.
These guys are flying through the stop sign with a Porsche Jesus in Beverly
Hills.
And so that was the cars pulling in the Ferrari smoking and all these people are
taking videos on people.
Like the whole neighborhood is out and they all have their iphones.
They're video taping it in the street.
So that happens.
And then right after that happened,
this incident happened.
So apparently a lot of these people like they're asking for diplomatic immunity
because they're rich and man,
but isn't that amazing?
I can't do that.
Well,
this is.
This is what they're saying.
Like some,
some of these people that do things like that over here,
you can't prosecute them because they have something called diplomatic immunity.
That's insane.
What does that mean?
That means is they have a lot of dirt on the people running the ship.
We're going to come over and do whatever the fuck we want to do more of what
kind of talk and more importantly they make a fuck load of money.
Shit,
load of money.
Yeah.
Every day,
all day.
Every day.
Dude,
look at this.
Yeah,
this is.
These got.
Watch this,
the yellow card to watch the Porsche.
Look at this.
The guy doesn't even stop.
There's cars to the left and to the right.
That guy just blows through this neighborhood.
Hey Man,
not the Middle East.
Can't do that here.
We'll see what all these people in the street and they're filming the Ferrari.
That's like a million dollar car.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
I think that's a La Ferrari.
I think that's a million dollar car.
Plus it might even be more than a middle of the GT three.
There's the big run.
I mean these guys have insane amounts of money and they're buying up giant
houses in Beverly Hills and homeboy do with the girl though.
We get in trouble.
I bet they don't know shit cash.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened,
but I know he got arrested.
I have no idea what the actual reality of the cases,
but I know the dude got arrested.
Crazy,
right?
I was watching Narcos,
artists.
This shit.
It makes game of thrones look like Harry Potter,
Dude.
And it's true.
I'm scared to get into it.
I just got just 10 episodes.
They
knocked out,
knocked out 10 and two days.
You're done with it yet.
I just finished this week.
Meanwhile I'm stuck.
I'm stuck on a bad show right now.
What?
Empire?
No,
the strain is empire bad.
I heard it.
You know what?
It's good.
The first,
the first season was good.
If you don't have anything else to watch,
it's good.
Fuck that.
No,
if there's no,
it's better than watching whatever's on at two in the morning on regular TV.
But man,
as season one or season two just started.
I just watched the season premiere yesterday.
Whoa dude.
Kenny Rogers is finally looking like Kenny Rogers again.
They reversed some of that,
a crazy facial surgery that they did on
them.
That was some sad shit dude.
He looked like monetarily Silva to know he got it.
It didn't look anything like him.
They pulled his face way.
Where do the girls do that too?
They get while they go to a bad doctor.
I mean,
apparently if you go to a good doctor that knows what they're doing,
they can,
uh,
they can tighten you up and it looks pretty good.
I feel like they all look the same.
They all look the exact same.
The ones that we're recognizing or the ones that are terrible.
I think that's why we say they all look the same.
I think there's some attractive older women that have had like little nips and
Tucks,
you know,
but I think when we see something like Kenny Rogers,
there's something hideous about it,
right?
If someone chose to squeeze their face tight to erase some of the lines,
bomber man,
you know what I mean?
Because.
Yeah.
Because especially that guy,
he was like this beloved character,
you know,
the,
the whole,
the gambler series.
Oh,
sweet.
Lefthand seats.
But don't you think those guys like the celebrities,
like they're so used to people seeing them for that so that they don't want to
ever let it go.
You know what?
Yes.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
We never sink this fucking show up.
We never do.
And Jamie pull up on the screen.
Who these guys are,
because this is a wild fight.
These guys fight
the duty stands southpaw.
The guy in the red with white.
He's got a nasty lefthand eaton shots and these guys are tired too.
They're in the third round here.
Are they from like a tough Japan or some those bullshit shorts?
I didn't bring my um,
I didn't bring my laptop today.
A full short says UFC road did Japan.
What is that?
Is that it has to be some sort of.
Oh,
this is like the.
Oh my God,
they're even shots.
So here's the gentleman's name,
how you say that
Mizuho Horchata and to Toronto.
Ishihara Ishihara is the guy with the crazy hair.
They didn't,
they have like a weird,
like,
mock tough where Barnett and Nelson were the coach or some shit.
Did they?
And there was like,
I'm.
So I was like on UFC fight pass may or some shit like that.
Like the countdown to Japan is almost too many fighters to pay attention to.
Oh,
for sure.
At the they're at number.
Oh Shit.
A comeback.
Hurghada oh,
sweet.
And right hand by Hiroto.
Oh my goodness.
That dude took a lot of shots to.
Dude.
Have you seen the Japanese ring card girl?
Very pretty adorable young lady.
Her.
I just,
I'm a,
I'm a fan.
Of course the American ones.
Very beautiful.
She was,
she might have went to number one from the Japanese one.
He's got bloody see this creature.
Let me ask you this about when it comes to girls bodies,
you prefer 10 pounds overweight or 10 pounds underweight?
Ten pounds over every time.
Right?
Every time.
Listen,
hop over.
Little fat ain't going to hurt nobody.
Little little belly roll.
Nah.
Gives you a little extra gas.
No one wants a bag of bones in the bed.
I feel everything.
I want to be
skinny for other girls.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
When you think when you see those girls walking around the ring,
they want to be like a skinny as possible.
Like in this culture.
In our culture in Brazil,
they don't.
They're not like that man.
Those girls are thick,
but they have flat stomach.
Yes.
They're in very good shape because we're in very good shape.
Well,
they're all in very good shape,
but there's just so much worry about putting a little weight on anybody.
Like a girl that has like a little,
like an extra 10 pounds.
If I'm managing the green girls,
they're fucking even Mickey d's.
You know what I'm saying?
They don't know that though.
Don't you think that they think they know?
All they do is drink fucking coffee and water and like ice cubes for dinner.
Especially a few days before.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Nah,
Nah.
Get that full rack of ribs.
Girls.
It's crazy.
Right?
It is.
So it's a weird thing because every guy talked to almost universally has the
same opinion,
like,
like a little bit of body weight on a girl doesn't bother you at all.
You're not my friend if you like skinny bitches,
fucking skinny girls.
No Way with like a skinny girls.
There's some skinny girls are hot as fuck.
So some girls are just sexy,
right?
I agree.
There's girls but the appointment,
but no one.
They don't look hot.
If they look like they're hungry,
you know she's not supposed to look hungry.
I don't want you to be all nervous because I'm going to
feed this poor kid Jesus Christ rice at the time when he come over,
that idea that these poor models have that.
They have to be coat racks like shit.
That's crazy.
That doesn't even make sense.
I guys want to be real big.
Most girls aren't in big muscular dude's just other dudes are.
You know what I'm saying?
There's guys out there that did look at a girl go,
oh my God,
she has an amazing body and she's really skinny and as big tits they liked the
big tits and like no ass.
There's a balance thing that I think people recognize and there's one thing that
a lot of like big weightlifter dudes do is if no one's coaching them,
they'll get out of fucking balance where they go way titty heavy and way bicep
heavy,
right?
Then they get these skinny ass next and you're like,
dude,
I know if the weight goes weird on you,
you can't handle it.
Look at that skinny neck.
You have this.
What is holding you together?
Like your pillar that the whole column in the center is made out of dog shit.
Like you can't do that.
You can't have giant biceps and old skinny neck.
It's just crazy.
Like those guys that compete in the Olympia.
Phil Heath is my boy,
but none of those guys or ladies,
man,
you know what I'm saying?
Like they don't have all these fact there so jacked.
I bet like you have to be one of those freaky bodybuilder chicks to be into that
for sure.
Or just be a girl.
It's just this girl sort of freaks.
Right?
They're like different.
There's girls that are like bodybuilder type chicken,
but they're just not that big that just.
They just started.
They're like a year and a half into it.
Perfect.
It looks like they're in great shape there.
They're probably going to get too big and a couple of years,
but they're like white belts,
shoulders,
man.
If she has like big shoulders,
I can't do it.
I can't fucking
do it.
You know?
I have a,
I have a theory about why a girl wouldn't be into a big body builder dude.
Like that type of thing wouldn't be bigger.
Is better because I think like evolutionarily,
like in the girl's DNA,
she wants a man that can survive and I think in everybody knows that a guy like
that,
like there's so much maintenance involved first of all,
and staying that big.
It's so preposterous.
It's so unnatural.
And how many flights of stairs can that guy go up before his heart explodes?
Super Fuck you mean for a regular person like Bill Gates,
you bribe.
Been like,
ah,
so your regular athlete at Guy Even the gym,
you know,
I do a few thing these guys don't have.
There's nothing in comparison to the demands that those fucking bodies have.
Not to mention.
These bitches are eating fucking chicken breast and asparagus every other hour
and just sweating and sweating,
sweating and have no body fat.
Like they're literally close to blacking out every time they stand up.
When those guys get down to that shred their asked cheeks have like fucking
rubber tire.
You know when girls crossed that threshold of the assets and hip start to lift
so much that it's almost like a guy's muscular ass.
Big Muscular.
I'm there.
It's rounded.
Fuck from the profile.
Looks fucking amazing.
But when you look at it straight back and she's walking like a dude too much
lower bar for sex,
like looks like Shankar went straight on that.
Did I ever tell you about this big 230 pound dude just pumped me in front of a
girl before.
But no,
my aunt hooked me up with this chick.
She used to always tried to hook up with chicks and she's like,
I got a new one for you.
She's at my,
she's a,
she works with,
her name is dawn and we're going to go out.
So I went out with.
I went out with dawn and my aunt,
we went to go meet a guy that my aunt was seen,
but he brings this giant 230 pound linebacker.
And so it's three dudes and chicks.
I'm like,
there's a little problem.
Where at Bennigan's?
Yeah.
And uh,
she wasn't drinking,
so I'm thinking this,
this is probably not going to happen tonight.
So we gotta go on the dance with this girl.
So freak,
zero alcohol and she's a freak.
She's all over me making out with me.
I'm like,
oh,
I got this one that it was in a bag
that we take a break,
we take a break.
The linebacker comes up and asked her to dance.
He's on the dance floor,
making out there looking at me,
giving me this evil look like.
I'm like,
Oh man,
this guy's totally dominating me.
Punking me jungle like right there in front of my aunt and this girl,
he's all over town now.
He owns a scrub.
The clubs over the lights turn on.
The lights turned on and
he's looking at me and he's leaning against.
We're trying to figure out what we're going to do and he's holding the lights
and he goes,
where you at?
Where you at?
Oh my goodness.
And I'm like,
man,
I'm,
I'm right here doing nothing.
Just shriveling up.
It turned into like a nightmare night.
So it's 1991.
There was no cell phones.
So the plan was to meet at my aunt's house.
Right?
I'm like,
okay.
I drove with them.
I go,
give me the keys.
You guys drank too much.
These guys have to follow us to my aunt's house.
Watch this little Honda prelude.
I'm on the freeway.
My aunt's go,
and you're going to lose them.
You're going to lose them.
I'm like,
no,
I'm not.
The right behind me.
Lost Him.
Got Back home,
my aunt on the phone trying to fit,
you know,
because you got to go to a payphone to get then call the house.
That can take 30 minutes.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I lost him on purpose later.
Last.
Try to pick up a girl with your aunt and then going to Bennigan's
if it works out,
if it works out.
If at the end of the story he has the best sex ever.
He and the girl they smoke a little weed and have the best sex of or something
like that.
But if,
but if the industry was that it was,
you know,
I had sex with her for 30 seconds for 30 seconds.
He did.
I wanted to get revenge on her.
Oh,
after all this.
No,
I didn't finish it.
We get to,
we get to my aunt's house.
I take it right back to the house.
I know,
I know I had 20,
30 minutes before that.
We're going to figure out where the hell she lived.
I lost my purpose.
So I,
I'm,
I'm gonna get a little revenge here.
So she was all over me.
She was just a wild girl,
had sex with him for 30 seconds,
and as soon as I was done she had just begun.
I said,
I gotta move my car really quick.
I'm going to get a ticket.
I'll be right back out in my car.
I was gone.
Never heard from her ever,
ever again.
I've never met a hot dog.
Hot Dog.
Really?
Oh yeah.
They're full full name though.
No,
I don't remember.
It was just dawn.
She was hot as fuck.
She was way too smart.
Damn.
I was way too stupid at the time.
I was like a 21 and uh,
she was uh,
at least my age,
maybe a year older.
She used to work for this comedy club that I worked at.
She graduated from Harvard with a degree in women's studies.
She's a terrifying conversations.
I bet.
Way Too smart for do this.
The time I was,
I knew it too.
Never,
never even tried to hit on her.
Never tried to pick her up.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm your intimidated way too.
Stupid brain.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
For sure.
She was hot too and yeah,
I just wasn't ready for that.
Our boy cocoon back.
Diego Brandao his last fight.
Tony Ferguson.
I think Merck got.
Damn Tony Ferguson scaring you.
Tony Ferguson is just.
He's capable of fighting a hundred percent of his ability when he gets in there
and it was a tough fight.
Now it's got a very tough fight with Tony Ferguson.
Does not fold up shop.
He's like a steady as a rock.
So game he.
So I haven't seen a guy game like him since our ideas.
Ideas.
It's scary.
Tony Ferguson is scary and the work ethic is incredible.
You can tell.
We can tell for sure.
It gets better every fight,
but this next one's a real.
I mean this is where we decide where he's going to go 100
off to the races.
The Habib,
Norma madoff where people don't know what the fight is.
Habib number got mad.
Office undefeated.
He's a former world champion and one of the best grapplers in MMA.
He's a fucking octopus and he beat the champ already in Dos Anjos.
Seton dos Anjos.
He ragdolled them.
He ragdolled dos Anjos.
And especially the second and third round he starts breaking guys,
but this pressure is fucking takedowns are nasty,
is ground up,
house nasty.
He's so dominant in grappling,
but he's coming off that injury,
a long layoff.
So if there's any time to catch him,
it's now and you know,
who knows how much damage he had done to his knee because there was more than
one injury.
There was several injuries,
like it wasn't just like heard it,
got it repaired,
did the proper due diligence.
And then came back.
There was another,
there was another injury I believe during Rehab.
So he,
he heard it at surgery,
went to Rehab,
did all that,
got better,
hurt it again.
So we're dealing with a real problem here.
And it also could be one of the reasons why he's so fucking good.
He's so good because he's relentless for Roche's bulldog.
Dude.
You know what I mean?
That mother,
motherfucker doesn't take a step back.
He attacks attacks.
That's all those boys at k though.
Yeah,
we'll think about it as well.
But particularly him.
Especially with the grand plan though,
teams got like that too.
But look,
look at his knees and look and look at dc had a knee injury.
But that's,
you know what man?
It's like don't,
isn't that like a part of that package,
like a part of that package is your red line in your body.
That's what it comes with the territory.
Right.
And you're going to break some shit.
Spar DC one time.
I was like,
what the fuck?
What the fuck are we doing?
Pressure?
Huh?
No,
just coming around.
How many want to go shop?
Eight.
Nah Man,
I'm cool.
She's just keeps coming.
Keeps coming.
We've never seen anything like it.
That's what happens when you work with Kane,
you know,
him and Cain both feed off each other and I think that was like a,
a,
like a huge contributing factor to who he is right now.
I agree 100 percent.
You can get that Olympic drive.
And when those two get together,
both of them together just fucking sharpening rockhold into the mix.
Oh yeah.
And a bunch of other guys there now to touch other guys in there.
Now where rockhold right now on fire.
That's a big fight.
That fucking December's the best fight in middleweight history.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I think other than the vandelay not vandelay other than the Anderson Weidman,
the first fight before weidman knocked him out,
but before that fight,
that was the biggest fight in history because Weidman was a crusher.
We knew why it was a crusher.
We saw a whiteman did the Munoz.
We saw this dude's just looks unstoppable.
Coffee's shit.
Super Solid.
Wrestler,
knockout power.
And then Anderson was the motherfucker and we before that fight.
That was the biggest fight.
Somewhere before that,
when he got in and I feel like we.
We've seen the best that I understand.
I think now what we did before that was the or fight man,
the fight before,
but he chose the matrix.
Joe,
you know what?
I know mom.
You're right.
Bonner's at the same level.
But the way he won was so shocked.
It was insane.
I was terrified and Banos on some shit and he was on some shit.
And then before that he had destroyed shale.
The veto or front kick.
I mean,
look,
Anderson hadn't even been in trouble except for the fight fighting.
Everybody knew he came into that fight with injured ribs pretty much after the
fight.
Everybody knew.
I just feel like I feel like Weidman's beating dudes in their prime right now
called beating dudes in the.
When you're talking about fucking monsters and now these two meet the both in
the front and Anderson fought Weidman.
Anderson rather was considered the greatest pound for pound fighter ever.
I agree.
I think at some point it maybe it was that fight maybe was in camp.
He lost that.
That edge.
You know what I'm saying?
He could have been that.
He lost that edge or could it be what Weidman's just that motherfucker.
He's just.
That could be that motherfucker,
but before that fight,
I think that was the biggest fight of all time and I think it still holds up.
I think this is right up there with them.
I just feel like style ron rankled Weidman's a better style matchup.
Like why men will.
No,
man,
I do.
I thought Anderson Weidman was amazing style.
Like it's always,
why am I going to deal with them on the feet?
You know what?
Because I,
I feel because I was going off trail and Anderson and chill could kind of do
whatever you want and kept taking him down to Kipp Tavi Nick,
right?
That first fight first and kind of basically beat him.
Then ended up fucking up at the very end again,
con that triangle.
I feel like I'm at a better striker than shale,
better wrestler.
So I feel like you put those together if you wanted to,
he could make it a boring fight and win that fight every time you got to.
You got a good point.
And you know,
you've got a good point,
especially about wyman submission ability,
who he's nasty.
He's submission ability is definitely,
but channels is underrated.
Mean did submit shogun and economy.
That gay teen.
I don't think anyone expected that shale can submit.
Guys who did the arm triangle to the arm triangle Stan Stan.
He's a motherfucker man.
He's a strong,
powerful wrestler.
You know,
chase has been,
had inconsistent performances,
but like when he was at his best in that Anderson fight,
especially.
Dude,
he's net.
How about,
how about the Marquardt fight?
He's fucking nasty.
Mean Chael Sonnen.
I agree.
He's a title to come.
I love chill and Weidman is a really good wrestler,
but I think like chill at his best.
He's.
He showed the same level of wrestling mobility.
But um,
but as far as the mixed martial artists,
that's just mixed martial artist.
Chris Weidman striking is nasty machita.
Yeah.
Much more dangerous with his power.
You see the Ryan Hall fight?
You've seen that fight?
Yes.
Back in the day.
Has the same left hook.
The same left.
Tosh hails.
Never been like a really good striker.
No.
Really like put it together.
Chuck GSP style.
He looked good in the Anderson fight the first round when he caught Anderson
with the straight left.
True.
He did.
He came out good.
Yeah.
But the difference I think is why many laser crusher,
he crushes guys and we has you hurt.
He turns into a fucking monster monster.
He turns it on and smashes.
Yeah.
You know,
you saw that in the first year I haul fight.
You've seen it in a punch of the fucking.
The Munoz fight was one of the most terrifying elbow.
Fuck man.
I think Weidman rockhold is definitely a fight for the ages,
but I'm as excited about that as I was the Anderson Weidman five for some
reason.
I'm
more excited about it with them.
I kind of,
I couldn't get any more.
I mean both of those fights to me like the top of the.
I agree.
I see that.
But you know what I'm saying?
I don't think this is the biggest one ever.
I think they're both like the same level of huge.
I think the Anderson Weidman fight is just as big as this,
this,
you know,
that fight was a crazy fight and the way it ended with Anderson Clowning,
um,
and why may catch him with that left hook.
I mean,
while it was happening,
I could not fucking believe my eyes.
I think it kind of fucked Weidman because no one took him serious and then they
fight.
They,
the rematch then fucking inches like falls off.
Right.
Then we're like,
fuck man,
but then widen it finally kind of gets his credit when he fights machida.
Right.
And then he destroys vittorio,
but he's still like,
why?
To me should be the biggest star in the UFC.
Yup.
All American dude beats the very best at one 85.
I don't give a fuck what division one to talk about.
One 85.
He's American.
He speaks well.
He's Super Smart,
right?
He's a family guy.
I don't know why it's not a bigger star.
You got a really good point,
man.
That's a really good point.
I mean it's not like he doesn't have the ability.
No.
He's like fucking are Nolan Ryan saying you think it's because he likes school
rep?
Just don't know what it is.
He's not a shit talker.
Right?
Ricky's not a big shit talker,
but no,
inside the gun.
He is a mother fucker.
Dude.
He's got something.
There's something about him that you can tell.
Like when guys go into it with him,
like they see it on them.
It's,
it's weird.
It's like it's.
So.
There's a few guys like that.
Like when,
when guys lock eyes with them to see it in them.
Yes.
And he's one of those and that's why the Anderson stare down with him was so
interesting when Anderson got mouth to mouth with him and Wyman looked and he
goes,
I'm not afraid of you dude.
Yeah man.
But there was a reality to it.
There was a reality to it that Anderson was like,
Oh shit.
Some shit.
What have I done know?
Weidman wants to fight at a.
He wants to fight Jon Jones,
Jon Jones.
And he thinks he can beat them.
Well it's illegal.
And Jon Jones had some shit going.
Well,
um,
I don't know what's going on with the John Jones situation,
but I know he comes fresh out of prison.
Beats the fuck out of anyone in the world.
He might not have to go to prison.
What do you guys think about?
Knows we haven't talked about the rules are to you?
I have no idea.
I wish them that.
I want to see him back,
man.
I just don't want them to keep telling this kind of behavior.
I think I liked John at his best.
John's a fucking really interesting,
intelligent guy with a crazy amount of stress,
a crazy amount of responsibility.
And you don't have a fighter like given the UFC right now.
We just don't.
Well,
he's definitely different than everybody else.
What about Nick Diaz?
What do you guys feel about that?
That's the worst travesty I've ever heard of an ego thing in any of the
regulatory decisions that I've ever heard about the center getting involved as
well that you're talking.
Shit,
they took his livelihood from five years for me that they did it based on one
test that's not nearly as accurate as the other two tests.
The other two tests which were run by the world antidoping agency,
the ones that take blood,
those are way more accurate and those.
He passed two of them.
He passed two of those blood cells
and then they take this urine test and they run it through this laboratory,
but urine is just not nearly as accurate.
It's just not.
So them getting on him for that is fucking crazy.
And then,
you know,
I think they were upset that he took the fifth.
Okay.
Four minutes.
Fifty six seconds right now in the cocoon.
Oh,
Diego Brandao fight.
There's an interesting fight.
Cocoon.
Oh,
have you never seen him before?
He's got a weird style.
A style that does not work.
Everybody will.
Tony Ferguson lit him up with Tony.
Oh Shit.
He got cracked again.
Bombs.
Jesus.
She goes ragdoll.
Oh,
that's fucked up.
That's it.
Diego.
Brandao.
Good.
God.
Vicious stoppage.
Diego Brandao.
That was Tommy hearns.
Marvin Hagler and shit.
Oh my God.
Beat down.
And Tommy hearns.
Marvin Hagler went a full round.
Believe it or not.
Went into the second round when God was open.
Coon iced.
Maybe.
Let's go back to the drawing board.
Huh?
Put your hands up.
Well,
cocoon.
No,
he used to have um,
a lot of success with that.
He has like a 45 degree front kick that he throws.
Have you seen it or it's like a combination of a roundhouse kick and a front
kick.
It's real weird.
He hit guys right in the liver with it.
It's fucking nasty,
man.
Eddie,
you've seen it before you.
The one who told me about it,
you were the first one who told me,
but you feel like you like.
Have you ever seen this guy in Japan?
He's throwing this kick.
You Go.
I don't think it's a roundhouse kick,
but it ain't like a front kick.
It's like something different.
It's in between and he started like A.
Yeah,
like a side snapping front.
Snap kick to the balls of your feet to deliver.
Not Anymore.
You know what?
When you throw a round kick,
when you throw around Kyc and you hit with the Shin,
it's probably the most powerful way you can throw it because your foot doesn't
give in.
Like when you throw a kick with your foot,
your foot kind of gives a little and you can hurt someone,
but it's not nearly as effective with like the ball of the foot as it is with
the heel.
The heel is way more effective because the heel doesn't have any give like this.
You can have a little bit of resistance because of your foot and it's like
hitting someone almost like with like a cushion behind it.
Yeah,
but the way cocoon was doing it,
you could tell he had done it so many times and his technique was so sharp.
There was not much movement in his foot and when he would pull his foot back,
he would,
you know,
really dig the ball of the foot in.
There was like really high level stuff.
Like a lot of cool Christian guys are really good at that.
They develop that ability to throw those front snap kicks with like they just,
it gets.
So the technique,
it's so sharp that at the end of it they're so good at like thrusting the ball
of the foot in there.
Yeah.
I think it's another one of those kicks ban.
We're starting to see more of a cowboy uses that a lot now.
He used that on Jim Miller.
He's thrown that front kick to the body,
but you're so same thing.
You're hitting the guy with the ball of the foot and bonded it.
Connor did it to Chad on or did it Kinda.
Does it align the body?
Uh,
Anderson did face.
Yep.
Anderson did it.
He was the first time is aiming just for the liver,
but he hasn't done it.
You have to say he's done it a few times in Japan and he's got some hands do
that he liked.
He has a great combo where he'll open you up with hands and then he'll just to
land that thing and then vice versa.
Well,
he hit Tony in that fight.
I mean he definitely caught Tony with some good shop.
Tony can take a punch to man.
I just think Tony Hits even harder.
You know,
Tony,
she might be the hardest hitter.
This weight for Rochus.
Tony Ferguson's ferocious.
Hey,
back to that ds thing though.
What,
what do they do?
What can you do?
I think they do.
I think they take it to court and I think they win easy.
I don't think there's a problem with winning.
I think if you look at the facts,
the fact that,
uh,
he passed to water tests that are much more stringent.
The fact that,
um,
you know,
there's a threshold,
like they don't want you to be high while you're competing.
I think that's reasonable.
What the thresholds are.
Very low threshold is so low or so high rather than like you could have smoked
pot a couple of days ago and you should pass according to Jeff Novitsky and Jeff
Novitsky should know.
Right.
So,
I mean,
I think they're reasonable about it.
I think what's reasonable or unreasonable is they're not willing to take into
consideration those other two tests.
Like give.
There were reason like if they looked at the chain of custody from the time,
like the blood was drawn,
it was all done to the water standard,
which is,
you know,
world anti-doping,
right?
If it was done to that standard,
they should accept that those are better,
more stringent tests and in fact they shouldn't even need to perform their own
tests as long as there's no suspicion of corruption.
There's no suspicion that someone's changing results are trying to protect a
fighter in the UFC doesn't do that.
Look,
it'd be if they did.
I mean,
she looked at all the different people that have been popped,
you know,
they wouldn't want those guys pop.
Although did you hear the bell for thing?
Did you hear that thing?
I was just going to bring that up.
I know,
I know.
You're right.
What you're saying.
I was like,
well,
when you're friends with Lorenzo,
well he had um,
apparently they had accidentally sent out some results of one of vittores tests
before he fought Jon Jones and he had been flagged as having high testosterone,
but I think this is while he had a testosterone exemption.
So I think the issue is not that he used testosterone.
I think he was allowed to then that was back when the UFC was kind of involved
in.
They were allowed to have testosterone use exemptions.
Yeah,
I believe so.
I don't correct.
I don't think he was doing anything illegal.
I think it was just high.
So I think like that they were talking about it in an article I read that the
doctor would tell you like say if you're the upper upper threshold is like
$1,200,
which is apparently like really crazy,
right?
If the doctor saw that you were 1100,
when they test you,
they,
they're like,
look,
you're a little high,
like 10 above 10 is high.
So we want you to drop your dose down a little bit and that that's what their
explanation.
What do we know what Victoria was that?
Well I know at one point he was tested at 1475.
Yeah.
Which is like super silver back.
Gorilla Hyena.
Dick fucked up.
But people have tested real high before.
I mean Nate Marquardt was actually pulled out of a fight.
Rick's Charlie Brennaman,
Charlie Brenham,
and took his place last minute and one against Rick Story.
Crazy fucking fight.
Biggest fight of his career.
And they pulled it out because of Israel results.
Who's that?
Hi.
Like he had an exemption.
Yeah.
And they looked at his results and they're like,
what?
What and what are you doing?
I know nate,
you know I,
well I know the,
the
tough titers when fighters are relying on Dr who's another ego you don't like
who the uh,
could you tell him how much did to.
I couldn't.
I don't want.
Who knows how much he's going to take to put him in.
His legal limit is his doctor now is Dr. gives them the same amount every week
and then he's giving it to them on a Monday and nate's getting tested on a
Friday.
He's had a chance for his levels to naturally go lower go.
But when a guy's about to fight,
the Dr. May likely say for best performance,
like if you want to fight at your best,
you should have it as high as possible.
So take your injection right before your way in or something along those lines
and that way it'll be at its peak the next day.
Or even if you're used to getting a shot on Monday and you're flying out to the
client on Tuesday,
you do a daily can fuck with the results.
You've seen that nate's not used to it.
Yeah,
but the point is that like when he was at the peak,
like whatever it's peak was that if that was normal that he was taken at that
level,
like that's not even human.
Like these are high,
what you call hyper human levels with doctors refer to as a hyper human level.
So you get to certain levels like 15,
1600 and you're like Jesus Christ,
you go into those freak bodybuilder levels.
What are the real pillars that those guys want to go?
They're not even human.
They take so much growth.
They're not there.
They're so ridiculously muscular and so just overwhelmingly cartoonishly
powerful.
Like you look at just dry age.
They get addicted to that man and I look at those guys and I think what's the
end of the road like for those guys?
Like how long can you run it at that?
I think you just get fat after awhile.
No,
no.
Look it up.
No located,
uh,
what's his face?
Homeboy from England.
A dorian yates is one of the best of all time.
He's in his fifties now.
He's fit healthy.
He looks thick.
It was thick.
Like you,
he's not thick like freakish.
He's thick like an athlete,
you know,
he looks,
he looks good,
man.
Hey,
he's super open about it.
Talks about all the shitty took,
talks about what everybody does.
I mean,
he's super open about it to tells you exactly what his dosage were.
He wasn't,
you know,
there wasn't any higher than anybody else,
but he also highlights that the reason why he got so good,
the reason why he was Mr Olympia was he was willing to fucking work harder.
Like it wasn't just the drop.
No,
they're all in June.
There.
There's a difference.
It's a work ethic.
However,
not a sport,
not a spectator sport.
It's something different.
It's hard to put it,
you know,
like how can you say that?
That is like boxing.
Boxing is a sport.
Soccer as a sport,
you're trying to win,
right?
You're trying to do something faster and move quicker when you don't move like
your,
your whole thing is standing still is your shit.
Your shit is desk standing still.
It's um,
it's,
it's an art form.
It's not one that I'm really into,
like you know that when you think about
it,
it's pretty homosexual,
man.
It's other dudes judging body Nigga.
You know what man?
It's.
There's A.
There's definitely a little weirdness to it.
I wouldn't say homosexual.
It's a.
What would you say?
Congratulatory.
That something.
Something silly,
but I see my boy,
my boy,
Kai Greene,
some shit that he did to make ends meet.
I'm
preparing myself.
Oh No.
What are you looking for,
brother?
Yeah,
they go grab something,
man.
Yeah,
I'll take one.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Kai Greene.
Who y'all taking care of brother?
Oh,
he did not call me Robbo.
Brendan,
before we get going on.
Thanks to Grillo's Grillo's pickles for hooking us up again.
Those are the best.
They're the.
They're the shit.
He's his.
He's growing now.
He's selling them in whole foods and all over the place.
Horse.
Delicious.
I met this dude and
this dude in a.
sorry.
I met this dude in a park in Boston.
He was in the park.
I was filming this scene in a movie with Kevin James and some dude had a pickle
cart and not thank you brother.
And I was like a pickle car.
Blue Fuck has a pickle cart.
So I walked up to the.
Yeah,
it was pretty cool.
I was like,
that's pretty interesting.
He goes,
yeah,
would you like a sample?
He was smart,
man.
They're pickles are so fucking good.
He's just handing out pickles.
And we were like,
Oh shit.
He's very clever man.
This shit.
So I do a show at um,
uh,
the Wilbur theater and dude gave out free pickles instead of like selling
pickles.
They do just gave out free pickles in the,
uh,
in the lobby.
Like just giving people pickle.
Guerrilla marketing can become an addict.
They're so good and you're healthy.
Delicious.
Pickles are good for you.
They're like one of those weird snacks where you're,
it's okay to eat bad about it.
You know,
the pickle juice,
I want to have sugar in them.
But the pickle juice people drink for electrolytes.
We used to have it on the sidelines.
This is um,
this is the tyrone tyron Woodley.
Johny Hendricks fight.
Didn't,
didn't woodley say that Johnny Hendricks bit him.
Denise say bit him or some shit.
He.
Oh,
face.
But see,
you know my band.
That's like a frozen moment in time.
It's real hard unless you see the actual video of what it looked like when the
hand made contact with the face because everybody knows that like in the middle
of a crazy grappling censorship,
occasionally a hand will go where it's not supposed to go.
Who gives a shit if you can kind of shape.
He is in.
Wow.
You'll throw both in amazing shape on both amazing fighters.
It's a really interesting fight.
Man.
Woodley is a training a lot now with.
I'm a duke.
Duke roufus help is striking out.
That's his biggest profits is striking really well.
I wouldn't say it's this problem.
I think he's,
I think his,
he's almost got like too much of a gift in his power and speed and when you use
that gift,
you know he can do shit like the way he can move.
He can move as fast as anybody through faster than anybody,
but that requires a lot
of energy and you gotta know when to do it,
when not to too long.
Yeah,
so I think he has,
because of that,
he has a.
it's compared to a guy who doesn't have that kind of horsepower.
He has a like a unique situation.
We have to.
He has to figure out when to sprint and when to lay back and I think you saw way
more than the Calvin Gaslin fight and that was a fight that he worked with Duke.
Duke is like such a smart,
polished striker that I think tyra can only get better training with him,
but at the end of the day,
what's scary about that dude is always that,
that fucking bum rush,
man.
See,
I think that's what he has to do with Woodley.
I don't think he say,
hey man,
let's drag this into rounds and try and be Johnny Hendricks.
You ain't gonna beat.
You know what I think?
I think you.
You get better at everything.
I think that's it.
I don't think like saying,
Hey,
the only way you can win this is a sprint.
I think that guy is getting better and I think they're all think you can up his
cardio 100 percent.
I really changes his approach.
Changes his approach.
Just slightly be a little bit more efficient and you know,
just know when to sprint when night.
And I think that comes with experience too.
Don't agree.
He has a lot of fights though.
It does have a lot of fights,
but you know,
coming into it as a wrestler,
when you think about the actual amount of strikelee here,
you seem like,
look how fast fuck Jesus fucking monster.
I think when you look at his actual striking experience though,
it's not nearly as much as say his grappling experience.
One hundred percent,
you know,
so he's got to catch up and certain what?
That was a crazy fight.
Him contact.
Jesus cried.
That was the big one.
The J here on fight.
That was the one where you say,
Jesus,
if this to his bum rushes you,
you gotTa fucking terrifying problem.
But then it didn't work in the Rory Macdonald Fight,
Rory Macdonald figured out a way how to solve the riddle that is that big right
hand.
And the bum rush kept his hands up high and did that.
Uh,
the,
the extension thing with his arms,
he's thrown a lot of jams going to drag in the later rounds.
Well,
rory avoided all the craziness.
Craziness.
Very,
very.
That's Ross do of Rasa.
Hobbies,
a wizard east.
Every seat is breakdowns.
He breaks down fights and talks about technique and why guys are good at.
He's one of my favorite casino as far as MMA coaches go.
He's number one.
He's the best I've ever been mad.
He was pretty.
God damn good too.
He's revolutionizing,
revolutionizing,
revolutionizing guard point.
Yeah.
I still think about his guys,
GSP now and then Roy Mcdonald.
He's had those guys since day one.
Well,
there's a few guys right now that I think they're all in the mix.
I think you're born mark Henry's in the mix for sure.
For sure.
He's so underrated that guy,
but he's all striking.
It's so ridiculous.
Kickboxers great blocks or I'm just talking about like straight MMA.
Coach Monster Wrestle in college too.
He did something,
but you know what dude?
How do you fuck with Matt Hume?
I mean,
look at Matt Hume's best student.
His best student is pound for pound.
The best guy on the planet earth today made my mouth may be fighting my maybe
fighting guys that are small and they may be sued or not.
Not the same sort of a talent pool,
but you can't tell me John Dodson is a mother fucker.
That mother fucker.
John Dodson is a Goddamn motherfucker and mighty mouse.
Shut him down and did so in the most efficient and impressive way I've ever
seen.
Mighty mouse is terribly got here.
It's not my number one,
top five.
Okay,
well,
you know,
it's all subjective.
I agree,
but he's my number one.
I think he's the best.
So and you watch mad human him work together and you watch all the strategy
that's involved and other thinking and all the technique and the work.
He's a mother.
Those two guys,
man,
you want to have a super team.
Jesus Christ for Rasa.
Hobby and Matt Hume on the same team.
Well,
what's impressive with Matt Hume is at that at the La lighter weight.
You have to be good at fucking everything.
No holes,
no zero holes and mighty mouse has that.
He's going to.
He's a black belt and everything.
Worldclass and everything.
He saw so,
so fucking sneaky man.
He's so sneaky like going.
He's when he's moving on those dudes like when I'm watching him move on dots and
I'm like this motherfucker in his foot work like it's never the same beat.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like one to one,
two,
one to.
There's,
there's all this sporadic shit that your brain has to try to process and that's
something that for Ross has talked about too,
like overloading a dude's mind with possibilities and I think for us it's really
the only guy I've ever heard articulated,
but you can see it in the movements of mighty mouse.
That's clearly what they're trying to initiate,
Bro.
Let's talk about Chris Weidman needs to do something.
Mighty mouse.
We gotta figure something out.
Something we'd a gimmick.
I don't know if he comes in with a Cape.
We got to do something,
man.
No,
man,
I got to figure something out.
I just hope if we keep talking about on people eventually figured it out.
I don't think for mighty mouse.
Maybe Henry Cejudo who knows a big fight,
but now Henry so who says he won't fight in Vegas?
[inaudible] and Nick Diaz and he don't smoke weed.
He doesn't even smoke weed,
but if for him it's a matter of principle.
If all every UFC fighter should do this,
you want to make a fucking change.
Just say,
hey,
we're not fighting in Vegas.
I'll change it.
You think?
Or they'll just say,
I think they would.
There's so much money.
You think they're going to change it?
I think.
I think they're going to lose the lawsuit.
First of all,
I'm pretty sure that for real,
that they're going to go,
oh,
100 percent.
They can't let this happen.
The key,
and by the way,
they've already lost when they had a lifetime ban on vandelay Silva,
they lost that.
You can't do that.
You can't give a guy a lifetime ban.
You can't callously take away a man's livelihood when he didn't even test
positive.
I agree.
Vandelay didn't.
You didn't do the right thing by avoiding the task.
He brought it up.
He ran.
We don't.
We don't know what he was on.
We don't know what the situation was.
We know what he said.
Okay.
We're just.
But all I'm saying is we lay it out.
You have to punish them for sure.
Right.
There has to be some sort of punishment,
but the idea of taking away the man's livelihood as a punishment for escaping a
drug test that if he was positive for would only get at the time,
I think it was a nine month suspension that was mandatory.
Right?
You can't do that.
That's a tyranny,
don't you think?
Just these Fox who checked as piss and blood of the baddest.
Sue's not planet,
just trying to flex their muscle.
They go home at night like,
yeah,
he's banned for life.
I fuck that dude.
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
I think it's the same problem that we have with cops.
In a lot of ways.
It's a.
It becomes a game of trying to win because trying like when you hear about
prosecutors and when you hear about like cops that are like hiding evidence and
prosecutors that are avoiding avoiding evidence or they withdraw evidence that
shows that they're the person that they're trying to convict may be innocent.
Yeah.
You hear about those stories.
You go,
how could someone do that?
It's an ego thing too.
That will also because they want the score,
they want to win.
Why do people cheat when it comes to like card games or pool?
Why do they do there?
They do it because they want to.
When it becomes a score thing and when you're arresting people,
it becomes a score so fucked up,
man.
Fucking place.
Think about.
Think about if all the founders got together like,
you know what you want to treat our boy nick Diaz like this.
We're not fucking fighting in Vegas,
but the big dogs,
students,
connor,
Rhonda,
fucking cane were like until you change this,
until he changes.
We're not coming.
They're mighty mouse.
We see fucking change really,
really fast.
A lot of people were disappointed in something mighty mouse had earlier this
week.
I didn't really.
The said he would fight,
but I didn't.
He was,
there was a quote that people were upset about,
a very particular quote.
Like,
I don't,
I don't remember what it was.
I don't know what it was.
I don't want to.
I wanna um,
parents,
can we get my mouth on pr guy something conor Mcgregor and is there some shit?
I don't know what's wrong.
What about that case where those kids in paradise lost.
They get,
they get accused of murdering these boys in the woods because they thought that
the dumb ass cops in the small town,
they thought it was a satanic ritual because they're there.
The animals would come and make eat the balls.
And the documentary talking about Dr. that documentary,
Paradise lost.
You got to see this and the animals would eat the balls and the dicks.
So they thought that these guys say tannic.
So they went to the high school and found the goth kids and fucking prosecuted
that.
So what happened to the boys?
They were in jail for like 17 boys who got their dicks eat and how they die.
They ended up,
they got their ticks eat.
Now they got murdered,
they got murdered,
but they,
they went after the goth kids because it was a satanic murder.
When,
who knows who did it that was ever convicted.
They never,
never found the guys.
But there's like,
if,
when you look into the story,
man,
you,
you some shit.
There's a deep dude.
It's three parts.
Paradise lost.
Do they ever in jail?
And they,
they,
they knew it.
And when they finally figured out that they didn't do it,
they decided to say,
um,
that was so much pressure with the supreme court that they did.
They didn't want to lose so bad that they said,
hey,
we'll let you guys out of prison right now.
But you got to admit that you did it.
Wow.
It was.
So they let them out instead of dragging on and dragging on another coma years.
They let them out.
As long as they admitted that they did it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's.
So they got them off the hook.
And then you let them out.
They still want.
They got conviction.
That was the most.
That was the most important thing.
By the way,
George Group is in the middle of fighting Mitchell cocky right now.
Four minutes.
Twenty two seconds into the first round.
It's
a fucking scraps.
I haven't seen George root fight night.
Grip it.
Did I just miss something or the last.
What?
Did he have a fight after the dominick Cruz fight?
Nah,
I don't think so.
Dominick Cruz made him take straightly case to just lay back.
Chill out.
Fuck.
Just happened.
I hear you.
Crews came out like a willdabeast.
Tj dillashaw.
That's a fight.
I hope he stays healthy and hope it doesn't fall off.
He's a beast dude.
He came running and like some sort of a wild animal at him.
I mean that was what it was like.
He was like,
fuck that warm like a Tasmania.
And I just went on Donald.
Yeah.
And then after,
when I was talking to him,
he's like,
dude,
I barely remember the fight.
You just saw red.
He just went into the zone like immediately into the sea.
One of the things I like about dominick specifically is the way he thinks about
finding and you,
you,
you see that when he does the UFC analyst position,
when he starts talking about like especially post-fight breakdowns,
what guys did wrong and I think he's really,
really aware of like movement and technique very,
very on top of the sport,
you know,
constantly.
Yes.
Him and DC are probably the two smartest guys I know about the sport as far as
current fighters in the sport.
You listen and Dominick Cruz talk like Jesus Christ,
like he was helping chill up for,
I forget who is going to fight,
but uh,
we were working out together and he was discussing these angles and his foot
work.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he's just his phd in footwork.
Yeah,
he's a wizard and I think he opened up a lot of guys eyes as to how frustrating
that shit was.
You know,
I think a lot of people,
well you know,
he's one of those fears,
these innovators,
these fighters.
It'll take like the steps and when they,
when they take these steps like you see everybody else go,
oh,
copycat.
Sure,
sure.
Well,
as a sport,
I mean I think the sport is still,
first of all,
there's more variables I think in mixed martial arts and there aren't any other
combat sport by far,
right?
We could easily agree to that and I think that just the unique demands of combat
sports,
the,
the ability to keep your emotions in check and to deal with getting your bell
rung,
getting blasted while you're in there and there's those variables.
There's so many.
And then the different ways you can fight the fact that you can take a fight to
the ground.
The fact that you have to avoid a guy trying to take you to the ground.
The fact that while you're thinking about the guy trying to take you to the
ground and punch you in the face because you're looking for.
There's so many variables going on that we're not even remotely done with.
Figuring out what's the best way to do this thing.
I don't know if we ever will.
I don't think we ever think it's constantly evolving into a lot smaller.
You don't have enough time to master it all.
There's so much to too many techniques in Jujitsu to master.
You add the wrestling and then you had the kickboxing and body type and body.
Certain body logic or your body.
Right.
Arguably the best.
Right?
That's the best body for the long strong guys.
His strikings getting better.
Right.
How'd Gracie?
It seems like,
I don't know if still fighting,
but the his last fight it.
He Won.
And Chad,
we decide to stop doing mma.
I think so,
yeah.
He's focused.
Yeah.
I think he won his last fight and then just said fuck it.
I think so.
I'm not positive he retired,
but I know he's doing way more.
Just seemed like a striking was finally coming together.
Good footwork and good chap.
Good Duma.
I'm a big fan.
I'm a fan of his Jujitsu too,
but you know who's.
Who impressed the shit out of me.
And then Neil magnifiers,
Damien Maia.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he's a Boa constrictor.
He,
I mean,
I knew it from the rick story fight.
I saw in the rick story,
find them like this is like a next level constrictor,
you know,
especially when he gets down to one 70,
he's a big ass one 70 at one 85.
He was like a good size.
It wasn't like undersized,
but at one 70 you can tell that with his technique and then the strength and
leverage the long limbs advantage that he's having God right now.
Super tear,
but it's the way he took the back and then when I talked to him about it
afterwards,
after the fight and he was talking about the adjustments that he had to make to
get Neil Macanese back and to finish them off because of how he was defending my
disguise.
He's on a very,
very high level,
high level.
Thank God.
I can't think of it.
Worst matchup for nail.
Then Neil took that fight against their Silva and then won that fight.
So back on track to Eric.
So if I was a good fight,
it was.
It was weird.
It was weird to see Eric Silva look like that.
Right?
Yeah.
A lot of people had questions about the way he looked physically,
you know,
I mean,
this is just something we're going to have to deal with in the middle of this,
this drug testing environment now,
like everyone's under suspicion.
Right?
And when you come in and your body looks radically different than it did before
and immediately people are going to suspect,
don't you think people have the right to suspect?
For sure.
Steroids and boxing.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Haven't figured out how to.
Boxing has been around for 7,000 years and they haven't figured out how to keep
that.
They don't give up together.
They don't give them me.
Tell you something right now.
Let me tell you right now,
the amount of testing that the UFC fighters go through is above and beyond
anything you ever see ever in boxing.
Ever get a floyd mayweather,
manny Pacquiao type situation where they.
They agree to water testing,
but even in that one we found out that floyd took a.
An Ivy.
Yeah,
Bro.
You're not allowed to take an IB.
That's boxing really under the U.
S antidoping agency rules because you can use an ivy and the ivy can mask the
use of any sort of steroid.
You're on,
Bro.
You ever seen the vendor holy field back in the day?
That was 30 Mr Olympia.
He's fucking Jack.
Well,
when he went up from positive,
you think that's positive,
but he got linked to a,
uh,
a steroid clinic under the name like Boli.
Holyfield Tyson.
He got fucked.
What about Tyson?
What do you think?
What do I think if I had to bet my entire life savings on it?
100 percent,
but I don't know for sure.
Who knows?
I know professional sports.
I'll tell you what though,
man.
When Tyson came out of jail,
remember when we saw Jack Tyson damage?
I could just crack George,
but two big shots.
You remember Jack Tyson?
Tyson fault.
Was it Kevin Ferguson?
Was that his first opponent right out of jail.
Is that was his name Kevin something.
Ferguson.
That's right.
Is that right?
Yeah,
that's right.
Like,
it's wrong because there was an Irish guy,
Tony Ferguson.
No,
no.
It was the Irish guy that he fought the first time out of jail.
I want to say Jacob.
Brian's right.
Leader mcneely.
That's it.
Jacob.
Brian is the guy fought in the UFC.
What am I talking?
Too Much?
Light.
Heavyweight.
Yeah.
Peter Mcnealy.
When when Tyson fought Peter mcneely,
diversity.
What he looked like from that fight.
Jamie,
pull up a picture of Mike Tyson versus Peter Mcneil like fresh out of prison.
He looked like a bodybuilder.
Look like a bodybuilder that fight radical.
Six pack fucking super buff.
So he was getting good nutrition in jail.
It everyone gets swollen in jail for fucking three square meals a day.
Terrible food they give you apparently
who the fuck would sign up for that fight?
Tyson fighting Jon Jones out of,
out of jail or prison.
Enjoy that.
I know it's going to be a mother fucker will also the amount of people that were
paying attention to that because they felt like Mike Tyson got railroaded.
Like that was a,
uh,
that was a questionable decision.
Like what had happened to him and the lawyers sort of strategy for dealing with
the case.
Was that the girls should have known,
she should have known going into a room that she should have known,
but also she should have known because of the guy that Mike is like,
their strategy was to like make it look like he was just a bad guy.
Look,
you should know he's out there at Merck and dudes,
you know,
go watch them harvest fraser fight and expect to.
What do you think's gonna happen when you get alone with that,
that big old room.
And that was essentially their strategy,
a lawyer strategy and that shit just didn't work this.
But the girl had a.
apparently allegedly she had a false rape accusation already before the Tyson's.
What's her thing?
So it wasn't,
you know,
look man,
some of these people
out there in this wild world of crazy.
If you don't,
you never know.
If Joey Diaz was Mike Tyson's lawyer,
what would that sound like?
Listen Cock sucker.
Everybody knows you're a fucking creep banging bitches.
You showing you a giant thick to the general public to plead the fifth,
plead the fifth.
I'm going to talk for you,
Mike.
You're the baddest of all time.
We're going to get you out of this shit.
The fuck you gotta.
Read books.
Get adult hands.
Break out the fucking interrupt your grandmother
in a fucking hotel.
Rome.
You wait lobster,
lobster.
Guarantee my bike Chris,
because you're my friend.
Come on.
So she claimed he just straight raped her.
Um,
I don't know what the exact was,
but there was like,
I really shouldn't be saying even saying what the evidence looks at.
Barely remember.
But there was something to the ics,
something similar to,
she had come up to the room.
She had taken off her panties shield in the bathroom and like they were saying
like,
that says that she was getting ready for sex,
which doesn't necessarily mean that could mean it was she needed anymore.
It was funky.
She took a leak.
She wanted to take it out of her vagina.
That's what the garbage is for,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't have one of those.
Yeah,
I don't know either,
but,
but so far there was no,
I don't think there was anything,
um,
that,
you know,
could have A.
I don't think there's anything that could have been done while while it was
going on too,
to make it.
If you're not there,
right.
To make it accurate.
If you're not there,
if you're.
If you're not the woman or you're not the man.
When you were describing something that happens when someone's alleging that
someone raped you,
you Kinda fucked when you're Mike Tyson,
you accused you of rape because I can see it.
But did he do it?
I don't know man.
I don't know either and I think that whenever he did the court said he did and
they put them away.
He still says he didn't know and I think like,
I don't know,
you know,
I don't know.
There's,
when you find out that someone had already gotten off of a false rape
accusation,
that doesn't necessarily mean that they can't get raped still.
You know what I mean?
It could be crazy,
but it would be like crazy cry wolf,
right?
Bitches to be crazy.
But who knows what the original circumstance was and she was really young,
super hot,
super.
You never know.
Maybe she was dating some other animal or something,
but I'll tell you,
you're guilty right away,
especially in the public if you're an athlete.
Big dudes.
Scary dude.
You're guilty.
Rather.
What the scariest boxer of all time.
I mean he's Mike Tyson in his prime was the all time of all time.
Hands down.
No one came close when he would go in there with that towel cutoff.
No fucking socks off.
Kid is Christ.
He was a monster.
But uh,
anyway,
who knows what the fuck happened?
That was my point.
But anyway,
when he got out of jail,
pull up that picture.
Jamie,
did you get that picture of what?
Uh,
you were close.
Oh,
it's a he so shredded bro.
That motherfucker faders on some shit.
Right?
And you see him dare you.
I'm not saying he's on some shit.
President workout program,
Bro.
Is that what he's.
Yeah,
he's getting three square meals a day.
There's no Jesus.
Oh my God.
Pull up.
Go,
go full screen with that picture.
Oh my God.
Hey Tyson got prison officer pregnant.
Damn straight.
He did look at that fucking mom.
I don't know.
That could be some bullshit.
Go to that visit page please.
Let's find out if that visit page.
No,
what am I?
What am I?
TMZ.
I don't even want to read that.
Of course he did
go back to the photo.
Fuck.
I don't want to hear the story.
I don't even want to.
I want to give it the time of day.
I want to admire his body and he fucked a prison
rap videos like those Tupac,
right?
Wasn't that one or two back when I get free dog where he was talking about the
girl,
the prison lady.
Look,
the two guys who escaped the prison earlier this year.
They were fucking the prison guard.
Yeah.
You can't have girls now.
You got a honey Dickerman and given the keys to get out.
I thought body on Tyson.
Jesus Christ.
If he could make it mean now that.
I mean,
is that the optimum?
Look though when you're fighting,
we look out.
For him it was especially how it was for that fight he provide mcnealy was out
of his league and other Japanese anime where there's like a girls that are cops
and detectives going after criminals and the criminals always fuck them.
You ever see that?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I love it.
It's always going after them and they almost catch them.
They catch him.
He seduces or Fox or any scapes and she's constantly,
you know,
that's gotTa happen,
right?
You see me cops and like super gangster dudes who have tons of money and big
dicks.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Especially in those cartoons are inspired by real event.
The situation like the girl has to go on to cover
and then,
you know,
Washington to cover.
She falls in love.
So I gotta try it,
you know,
she tries to pull the card at the end of the rest of.
But she can't do it.
She does the same every.
She almost has him and then he just fucking talks her into sucking his dick.
What is weird?
Japanese anime octopus's,
they'll have like octopuses are getting fucked by like multiple armed animal
cartoon.
This is a cartoon.
This is real life.
No enemy.
Right?
You know what I'm talking about,
right?
Why?
Why is that bus with?
Yeah,
there's.
Is it just tentacles is a tentacle porn?
Is that what they call it?
Loves Sushi.
Funny because
for the last couple of days I've been really into what's going on youtube and
just watching a intelligent octopus documentaries and where they test their
intelligence.
Do you know that off the coast of Washington they have a problem with.
There are certain areas that they have a problem with in the water where octopus
attack you and they got it on film,
like attacking these divers and octopus man.
You heard of this?
Well,
they're predatory you.
Have you ever seen the video of the meeting sharks?
No.
Damn.
Like a giant squid who up the video of octopus kills a shark because there was a
problem that they had with this aquarium where these sharks were dying and they
thought that like someone was stealing the sharks or they thought that maybe
like one of the other sharks was killing the sharks.
They couldn't figure out what the fuck was going on.
So they set up a camera and in the hidden camera they found out that octopuses
are gangster as fuck.
Yeah.
They're so smart.
They hide in these rocks and they pretend to be the color of the rock that could
change their color to look to look like their background.
Like they camouflage themselves and while there's sharks
swimming by the octopus just fucking explodes out and grabs him and eat him
alive.
It was one of those bullshit sharks so.
Well,
it's a small shark,
but it's just when you put these motherfuckers in captivity,
the sharks don't give a shit as long as they have food,
they're kind of dumb.
But octopuses are not dumb.
Octopus are smart.
It's fun.
I love a good Octopi.
Occupy might be one of my favorite animals that actually captured on film.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
He's about to Merck.
This fucking shit.
Once they knew that the.
The footage ain't that good.
It's not bad dude.
Once they knew that the octopus was doing this,
they set up all sorts of cameras.
You see how they edited the Shit?
The edited.
I bet.
I mean this is.
That was probably taken three weeks.
We got to edit it.
Well,
I think both both scenes are probably bullshit stuff like all this stuff.
This is like we gotta build the story,
knows a little bit too much about the business.
You know too much about the time I watch the discovery channel.
How did they get the cameras?
All over the.
The weaving a story.
How many cameras did get the camera in the water like that?
Eddie Bravo can't watch a fucking superhero movie.
It's like,
come on,
you know he's going to win.
He always wins.
Like,
why would you watch it?
If you know what's going to happen at the end,
Do you know?
Do you think he's going to lose?
Did you think he was going to die at the end?
Was over?
Were you shocked?
Were you surprised?
Like,
Whoa,
the good guy.
The good guy always wins.
I want the bad guy to win.
Why can't the bad guy?
When I went to Baghdad,
when once I like Narcos,
I want to watch this.
Is it got a little bit?
Yeah.
They just squeeze the life out.
Jack will their tentacles,
man.
They're tending.
Their tentacles are not just strong as fuck,
but those suction cups have prongs.
They reach out and cleaning and rip things apart.
Like it's not a simple as like,
those are just like soft suctions,
Holy Shit,
don't really have a hook in their mouth.
And if they lose a leg,
the leg just grows right back.
Show gangster.
And they have eyeballs that are there.
They are really effective,
but there is so different than ours.
It's like a completely different branch of the evolutionary chain that,
I mean got a bitch,
you know?
No Shark.
Yeah.
What's crazy is when they're born and from day one they're on their own.
So that's why they're so skittish and they hide all the time,
but if you raise octopus in an environment where they don't have anything to
fear,
they go right up to you.
When there's these octopus and these cove,
I'm watching all these documentaries,
there's this octopus and it's coded where they're not afraid at all.
You Go,
you go into the water,
they come right up to you and look you right in the fucking eye.
They go right up to you and swim around and check you out.
They're not scared to shit.
But in the wild since you know,
since day one,
they're by themselves.
They don't.
Their mothers don't raise them.
They're just skittish and they're just hiding and shit all the time.
Well,
I think when they come in contact with people to,
if they have any sort of means of communication,
they would let them know that people are dangerous.
What they are really smart.
If I don't know how smart octopus are,
I mean,
I know,
right?
I don't know how much information they can transfer.
There's all these videos of them doing.
They learn really,
really quick.
Like what?
They'll take an octopus,
a wild octopus,
they put it in an aquarium and then they put a crab in some glass container
where they could see the crab and they can't figure out how to fucking get the
crap.
But then they in the next a container that an octopus that knows exactly how to
get them.
So the fucking octopus is watching.
The other one opened shit up and he's right there in the octopuses like all
excited going,
going like this.
Oh Shit.
So then they give them,
they give,
they give them another fucking crabbing.
This glass container.
And that octopus.
Just
quick,
can you look?
An octopus attacks human.
They got do this octopus on the picture.
You with that shirt on?
A diverse head.
Octopus.
Scarier than a blanket shot.
Get it.
I get it,
dude.
I would rather be in the water with a shark than a killer.
A killer occupies.
And how big do you know how big would the before you start freaking out?
I mean we're talking about us like a giant squid,
like moby Dick Squid.
You'd have to start getting nervous.
But Hey,
but here's the thing,
200 pound octopus on mount.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's,
that's enough.
Fuck that.
Especially in the water,
it wouldn't even take that much.
When you take a 70 pound on that thing
was on his head low.
If you get.
If you're in the water.
Okay.
A really big one,
like a 50 60 pounder could kill you.
It's real possible drag you.
And they could bite your tank.
They could bite your.
They have beaks,
dude.
I mean they can tear flint not far.
Not Blast.
You're right.
They're not fast.
But if you got caught up with one of these in a tangle in the water,
how are you going to swim?
How are you going to swim away?
Like what if it cuts your cable?
If it's that smart and it cuts your scuba cable,
you're a dead man for sure.
Unless you can get to a knife,
stabbing shit onto getting attacked.
August.
Did you guys.
You guys are discussing what would happen and they're showing you what's
happened.
This
mask,
he's taking off his match,
jumped on his mask.
Dude,
I'm telling you.
Look at this.
This guy.
The Camera Guy's not helping Jack Legos.
Yank it off.
Yeah,
but he's got to be careful,
right?
Oh my God.
That's a big EXEC.
I'm not talking about.
Once you
do this isn't a problem in Washington off the coast at octopus that attack.
How many people die a year from mocket?
This?
Look at the.
See.
See The fucking beak.
I'm not worried about
the movie,
right?
Like some bunch of 20 year olds go camping off the coast of Washington.
Jamie.
Rewind that because it's like a thing from the alien,
from the movie alien.
Look at the tongue.
Comes out,
look at this.
Meanwhile,
homeboys on screen crying his eyes out to do.
They might be,
they might be aliens or they might live in the ocean.
I'm going to go with Joe
here they are
animals from another planet.
Yeah.
This guy's getting jacked.
I think it was just trying to test them,
but you know,
they're um,
they found these fossil remains of what they think was an enormous one.
The problem with one of these things die.
We don't know how big they used to be.
You know,
we know like megalodon existed,
but we know that basically because of his jaw,
because we don't know what,
how big their like their beaks were and like there's times they can't find their
bodies because their body's deteriorate,
but they have fossilized remains of enormous suction cups in like an octopus
tentacle formation that they think indicates that,
let the,
those mysteries of the cracking where they would talk about this enormous
fucking octopus that could take down the ship and the sailors would see them at
CNB terrifies some scary shit,
could've been bullshit,
but they have these fossilized versions now of those tentacles of suction cups
that are making scientists reconsider and they think there might have been an
enormous one.
Like they never even saw that giant squid until like a few years ago.
I'm just saying the octopus now,
not scared to dudes are going to train octopus to jerk him off launch.
That's the future.
No Man.
Little pokers in those,
those two.
You gotta you gotTa clip up.
Clip the pokers bonkers.
Like,
you know,
you give your cat what do you do when you put it in here?
But um,
you
know,
you pull his teeth out,
you guys have the wrong Richard Gere,
you break,
you know,
you shake them down.
No,
you just pull the teeth.
I'll put them in a giant condom,
like a bicycle to
go rob dawg on Ligo.
Raw.
Terrible.
But if you want to do it safe
to say you've got to break down,
I would never do it without breaking.
Their job is put it inside you.
Hammer fist.
You just hold her head down and go.
Which just wonderful.
I'm Josh Barnett Versus Roy Nelson is the main event here.
And this is interesting watching Josh Barnett back in the [inaudible] pride his
font while.
No,
he hasn't.
He hasn't fought since Travis Browne,
correct?
Correct.
But he's been doing metamorris,
but that's a different animal.
Ellen at grappling submitted here on Gracie.
That is not easy.
Yeah,
he's a beast.
Dude.
Submitted Dean lister to WHO's even picking Dean least are there you go at least
least least least or bowling.
He was one of the first guys to submit dean in like fucking 15 or 16 years
forever.
Eddie
in competition I think.
I remember right.
I mean,
maybe it was like as a black belt ever,
but whatever it was,
it was super and prettier.
We betting on this main event and Co main event what we're betting on the main
event not to kill me.
I got Barnett Barnett.
See,
I think,
but it's going to win,
but I'll bet you for the sake of it guys,
don't take it off.
I think he came his way out of the thing.
Josh is too expensive to eat that one.
I think guys have figured out Roy.
Right?
And it shows because he's won one.
I was last four fights.
He's one in four.
Have left five I think.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think a great deal has been fighting.
Tough.
Tough guys.
Oh,
I can always turn the lights out on you man.
But when you're finding out that like Josh Barnett,
man,
they got a huge right hand.
Cool.
We're going to.
We're going to minimize that.
I'm going to get you into the cage.
And really,
you know,
we talk about Roy being a black belt,
which he is.
Don't even run under Henzel Gracie.
But Josh Barnett,
some motherfucker,
he's gonna get you down,
he's going to get you down.
You certainly a motherfucker.
And if you remember Frank Mir,
verse Roy,
Nelson,
matter of frank,
I'm against the cage,
was taken down kind of whooping his ass when I see that.
I think Barnett's looking at that footage going right when you going young this
cage,
when I get them down and do work.
Yeah.
I don't know about that fight.
Um,
the um,
because how impressive was Josh?
He gets Frank Mir.
Super impressive.
I mean,
he,
he made Frank Mir looked like it was towards the end of his career.
And then Frank Mir after that one on this big combat time off.
Yeah.
But when you look at that fight,
that's,
that's a big part of it,
right?
The time off is a big part of it.
That's a really important point actually.
I think Josh Barnett is super crafty man.
He knows so much.
He's such a veteran.
When we look him in the UFC,
especially this comeback.
He's one and one,
right?
He beat mayor,
which at the time it wasn't like the mayor now,
but he smashed it smashed and he did it in a pretty ruthless way.
Charged with that.
Sent him with that knee.
Yeah.
Well he also.
Then he got hurt.
Then he got murked by Travis Brown did and they took a bunch of time off.
He got Travis Browne that,
that one technique that travis use on Gonzaga and he used on elbow to elbow with
with that widespread that he has.
When is,
that's all we trained.
That's all we trained with,
but it's fucking takedown defense is so nasty.
So why so fucking tall?
That elbow comes fast too.
I,
I just think.
I think Barnett with Roy,
I think.
I think Steve Bay was the first one.
Let's just avoid this right hand and go to work and Josh is such smarter fighter
than all these other guys.
Well,
I think it's super interesting,
but we're also assuming that Roy hasn't figured out that it needs to make some
adjustments to too late.
Brother.
I don't know about that.
Really.
I disagree.
See what I know about Roy's,
he got good at Jujitsu,
enough to be a black belt and not enough to be a highly considered black belt,
beat Frank Mir and they're grappling competition like to.
To get that good at grappling,
you have to be able to solve problems.
So if he is really good at this one thing that he already knows,
he's really good at knocking people.
Talking about a young guy when he competed and all that.
Yeah,
but don't you think that he's just as hungry now?
It's probably.
It's ever been before and I never see that
guy.
I disagree.
Looking like he's lost his enthusiasm for things.
He's always been trying to fight the best guys in the world.
I mean,
and he's had some spectacular results against high level guys like who the check
Congo fight when he knocked out check Congo check.
Congo is pretty highly regarded right?
Mitch,
when he has been highly regarded.
Yeah,
after the Cain Velasquez fight,
especially.
God Damn.
That was a while ago.
It was and he still loves it.
He knocked out a pat barry,
Pat Barry Fletcher.
You can come back.
It's a long time to stop.
I
stopped taking that
medicine man,
Pat Barry Street.
He gave him his mailbox keys to his apartment.
Pat,
you know,
I love you,
but Pat Barry's not a world class guy,
but at that time Pat Barry had never been knocked out before in Congo.
Knocked him out with one punch.
That's fact.
That is a fact check.
But Pat had not been knocked out before and that sort of started like,
uh,
a series of bad losses that pat had fought tougher guys.
Pat as a wild dude,
he came hard and strong and had him hurt.
Sure.
Was an amazing fat.
One of the best of all in Congo.
Came back and knocked him out.
So I got,
I think Congo is pretty highly regarded my opinion in an MC.
And then after that Roy knocking them out.
I thought it was pretty.
I'm pretty sure that's the way it happened.
I'm pretty sure roy knocked him out after he had the war with pep.
That's correct.
I just think that,
uh,
Roy has some stupid power and you never know with a guy like that man,
what a guy has that kind of stupid power.
If Roy hits you,
if you fuck up,
if zig zags over the dude can shut it off.
But when you get to a certain level and you only have one thing,
I'm not saying royal has one thing,
but if your right hand the motherfucker and you get to a certain level,
these pros pros go,
okay,
not getting caught with that.
And it showed him because he's one wanting one is fine.
I think,
you know,
it's cute too that he has that look,
with the big bell and he rubs his belt.
He gets on top of the octagon.
But I think the reality is he would move better and fight better if he didn't
have the hundred percent.
It's amazing how far he's gotten with all that extra body fat.
It's amazing.
He's world class 1:55.
That's a stretch.
That's a good.
First of all,
how dare you.
How dare you cover of the Ugi right now.
Come on,
fuck it.
Front page,
Eddie Bravo says Roy Nelson could make
he got his diet together.
No
fibers are legit to a fight.
He's a thick dude man.
But I mean look,
maybe working skinny the fuck out of himself and make one 85.
But if he did he'd probably be in hell two.
Oh,
five.
Two.
Oh,
five reasonable.
Okay.
But if you waste,
what is he way to 50?
What do you think he weighs?
Yeah.
Two 50.
Five to 50.
How many pounds overweight do you think is.
If you look at that big giant belly?
No,
I don't know.
How much is that overweight?
I mean like what
used to be 300 pounds and he thought at 300 pounds and then he got down to one
70.
Yeah.
But Joe,
Joe Riggs was a different thing.
I mean not that tall.
I think when we first started
losing weight,
Joe was like really obese.
I think it was a different kind of like lego obese arm.
Obese.
Like Roy successful at that successful.
Well you sold.
It's weird because he's only got it in the belly,
like his arms aren't fat.
His arms are like it,
like a stocky guy on
his bellies.
This giant belly and muscular like you don't have like the definition of his
shoulders.
Look at Mark High Mark.
Mark Hunt carries his body fat like all over the place.
He's got his body fat and his arms
and his legs,
but Roy has it mostly in his belly.
He's like,
he has it all on his belly.
I'm not a nutritional expert so I could throw some bro.
Science takes a bro.
Science like a motherfucking.
Someone called dolce immediately.
We need to find out.
I don't know what.
What makes a guy's gut stick out more like when you see a guy and he has that
giant belly,
but everything else seemed sort of normal size.
Like what is.
Is that a diet thing?
Is that a generic is just as genetics goes to the Sony guys?
A giant bellies but the legs are kind of normal.
It's like a girl though.
Sometimes girls eat and they just have these fat ass is bro.
So,
and then the arms in the stomach,
I used to work with this guy and he was a construction guy and it was,
it was the weirdest,
the weirdest body of all time.
His,
his legs were normal sized,
his arms are normal size,
his face was barely fat and then his chest was fairly normal and then he had
this crazy fucking belly that didn't make any sense to.
You would just look at his belly and go,
what in the fuck?
But then I thought about it one day.
I was like,
oh,
that guy would have to do is get rid of that part of his body.
And he's like a guy placed on a regular basis hitting the gym,
taking a spin class.
He looks like a normal guy.
It's a big if though,
sometimes it's a,
sometimes it's a kind of a hormone issue,
right?
Like it's hormone glands straight bro.
So science Nelson's a motherfucker bro.
Science.
It's just a bunch of dudes.
Straight bullshit
documentary bro.
Oh Shit.
It's a hormone thing.
Times.
It's good to not have google nearby.
True.
You know,
just to like have fun,
spend way funner.
Brings us back to the old days,
as long as no one likes to pretend they don't like to pretend that a,
they know what the fuck they're talking about,
bro.
Science goes down the chain,
you know,
because whatever you tell me that I tell someone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Times I've said that so many times I heard that.
You know what?
I always do that.
I'm pretty sure it's a weird thing though,
man,
like people's People's diets.
You know,
I've been paying attention to my sugar intake lately over the last few weeks,
but I just,
I'm shocked at how much sugar is in things that I didn't know.
Do you know that low fat milk for the most part has sugar and eight grams son,
they put sugar and low fat milk because otherwise it's just nothing sugar,
low fat sugar or low fat milk rather don't drink it.
It has no nutritional value.
None because all the things like vitamin D,
vitaminK ,
vitamin E,
they all have to bond a fats.
So like the,
the,
there's no fats in the milk,
so it's like you're just drinking water.
Like nonsense.
I like milk.
I like almond milk,
almond milk and rice milk,
almond milk.
Again,
same thing though,
if you read the ingredients,
that shit is all sugar son.
You can get zero sugar.
Unsweet sweetened,
unsweetened.
It's delicious.
Zero grams of sugar.
The most of the stuff you get though has the.
Like the.
The treatments have unsweet no.
Duncan trussell called me up and he's like,
dude,
fucking.
I've found the best almond milk and so amazing taste.
So good.
It's good for you.
I don't know why.
How's it tastes good?
He goes,
it's delicious.
I go,
Ooh,
did you check to see how much sugar's in it?
And so we did it on the phone and it was just some stupid amount and it was
probably like a little baby glass.
They know you're not going to have,
you know you're not going to have a big glass.
I know some tastes good.
Has Sugar.
That's my biggest problem.
That's my sugar by worst sweet tooth man.
Sometimes I wonder why.
Work out so hard so I can eat like shit.
Do you want some mangoes with Chili on them right now?
I'm never mad at that.
Jamie.
Where are those fresh mangoes?
No,
no,
no.
Like dried mangoes.
This is my problem lately.
I have.
I have an issue.
Mango sticky rice baby.
I'm avoiding sugar and that my number one issue is he's fucking trader Joe's.
Mangoes with Chili on them.
They have.
I know it's got sugar in it.
I don't even want to read what David.
The sugar bro.
These things right here.
Do you like those Eddie?
I haven't had that.
Oh,
you get Eddie?
One of those too,
please.
Because I'm Mexican.
Yes.
Yeah.
This shit is delicious.
Who makes this one a lot?
Next?
I know it's got sugar into.
What does it say on the back?
It's almost like it's so good.
It's like,
let's figure out what.
It doesn't have to put that.
Free cholesterol.
Cholesterol free.
Well,
yeah,
of course is no cholesterol in it.
That's silly.
No.
Funny that it says No.
Nuclear energy.
Merck non mercury.
That's hilarious.
No mangoes have mercury.
No mangoes have cholesterol.
Like what are you using butter to make your mangoes cholesterol so stupid.
It's gluten free.
It better be shit if it's made out of bread that it's not really a mango.
You Fuck
Eddie Bravo.
Opening it up.
Chico Caymus or a Gucci for Gucci first fight.
Since he last mighty mouse could be very interesting.
Hard Gucci's fast as shit to.
And Chico came.
It's pretty slick.
I thought Chico came look real good.
And his,
uh,
how much sugar intake.
The first ingredient is mango,
second ingredient.
Sugar,
sugar fuckers.
They didn't even try to hide it by saying
fuck it.
I wonder if one's better for you.
Heart Gootchie dude.
Heart Gucci's fighting Chico Caymus.
I forgot about this fight.
This is a good ass fight.
I thought Chico came look really good against your boy Henry.
So hutto.
That was a great fight.
How bad was it?
Good.
How bad is bad?
Motherfucker combat or artificial sweeteners.
When a co a soda companies advertise,
we use real sugar.
Bad is appertain.
Jesus Christ this point in time,
that's all sugar people want,
man.
I'm addicted to it bro.
I'm a dick.
They weren't real sugar.
People want real sugar now,
man.
They.
They feel like it's too risky to get involved with aspartame.
All of it's bad for you,
dude.
The reality is you're only supposed to get sugar from actual foods like sugar
from fruits,
sugar from apples,
you know,
sugar from things that taste sweet.
That's how you're supposed to get your sugar.
Like this creepy way that we've got of like sucking all the sugar out and
stockpiling it,
and then injecting it directly into our bloodstream and the foreign of candy
like that is.
That's a drug.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
And it's.
And it's completely alien to our system.
I feel great though,
but you know who needs it apparently.
Is those a super triathletes and marathon runners and shit.
They need sugar dude.
They say people who are real explosive needed for the lights
to be explosive.
Who's that guy?
That was a body type.
Who's the guy that was fighting mma?
The fought Tim Silvia.
Tim Silvia.
Beat the fucking shit out of him.
He was the strongest man.
Ray Mercer.
No,
no.
Hold a starts with a P.
I can't remember his name.
Um,
he's strong man.
When right.
Poland.
He fought housekeeping.
Real meathead.
Yeah.
He's.
Oh,
he's the biggest of big.
He's a giant dude.
Went 10 time world,
strongest bank context.
Some shit.
Super powerful dude.
And he hits a lot of candy.
Apparently.
He's a big part of his training,
but I guess he's just blowing his sugar levels out of his muscles,
so not so much steroids,
so it don't.
It doesn't fucking matter.
What.
Do you remember that number?
That real buff guy that was the mascot for the killing the cage normally do with
a huge bodybuilder.
So they would use them for like,
like in between shots of like fights.
Why don't you explain how crazy that was when I was down when he had a photo
shoot because I had to do like a photo thing because I was a commentator so he
never got to knock out a bunch of photo shoots and he's sitting there in the
waiting room with a gigantic bag of skittles killing skittles and asked and he
said,
you got to get the biggest pump.
You need sugar running through your veins to get the biggest pump.
Wow.
Sugar
skittles.
Right before the photo shoot,
sugar makes the world go round.
These dudes that lift that much weight,
I think they just blow their sugar out of their body.
I think,
you know,
their requirements are just so high.
But how crazy was that king of the cage thing because the whole thing was they
had these mma fights and then they had this guy that was supposed to be the king
of the cage and the guy who supposed to be the king of the cage was
just an actor or a bodybuilder.
So did you Jitsu.
But.
But he wasn't fighting.
He wasn't the king.
It wasn't like he was the guy that was at the top of the heat.
He was the guy that locked the cage before the fights.
Yeah,
but how.
But it wasn't his organization.
He was just the guy that terry and bud hire guys.
Awesome.
What,
what was his boss?
Ruden owned.
He was part owner,
right in the first one.
So the logo was like boss
when boss Rutan bolted from King of the cage.
They kept the logo,
but then they just turned it into a real dude.
That's hilarious.
These things are a mother fucker so good.
So I'm going to eat this entire bag.
Of course you are.
I told you this is my problem.
I think my mom had like maple syrup and activities when I was a straight up man.
I cannot get enough of it.
Oh,
that's so silly.
Meanwhile,
this is a good fight.
Chico caymus and hard Gucci.
I'm not gonna lie to you guys.
I haven't watched one single thing.
Heart Gucci's fast as fuck man.
My guys remember these.
I'm sitting here listening to you guys talking about fights and I don't.
I feel like I'm not a real fan.
No,
you're running 100 fucking Jujitsu schools,
you know,
but you're,
you're,
you're 100 times more busy than I am and so are you.
Yeah,
but this is my job.
It's part of our job.
I mean,
my job especially I'm the commentator for the UFC right now.
There's no,
no,
there's no way you could.
You can have all that information about all these fights and fighters and what
happened in these fights in the second round.
The third round.
Rocketship.
Unless you watch them again.
Well that's why
you watch it some twice.
You watch them twice.
It depends on the fight.
There's somebody I want too much.
Dude,
I got to.
You have no time for shit.
He doesn't sleep,
but I wonder if you haven't watched narcos yet.
I just remember them.
Dude.
It's a different thing when you're calling fights,
especially when you're calling fights you.
You remember more.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Dude.
You don't fight tonight,
so don't say wilder memory.
Extraordinary.
That's the thing.
You and Brent,
do you watch it twice.
Are you watching all day?
You wake up and I got to watch it as it
as it.
Come on,
man.
You have to have a good memory to be a comic,
to do an hour long set and to do a new hour long set every year or so.
You gotta change it up.
You have to remember old shit.
You have to remember new shit.
You have to.
You have to be able to rememorized things.
You have to your super targeted.
Um,
how do you deal with your children farting?
Do Laugh at that.
Do you laugh?
It's hilarious.
The five-year-olds figured out.
It's hilarious though.
Now you won't stop farting.
So my wife gets bummed out and I think it's hilarious.
I'm laughing so there's no cooperation.
So the five year old,
the other day she,
she's in bed reading stories.
She grabs the back of her knees roles or bumped in there and blast
went up to the fucking howling.
I think it's
funny.
It's an absolutely funny,
but she tells them she doesn't think I should necessarily encourage it and she
said you shouldn't far and I'll say,
hey,
all right,
you got to stop farting.
But the problem is in my house,
like laughter is valued very,
very,
very heavy in my house.
It's always laughter.
We laugh about everything and we joke around about stuff all the time and we're
always like,
like if,
if something goes wrong,
even if something goes wrong,
they do something that they shouldn't do.
There's always some laughter involved.
Always.
So like when,
when she finds out that she could make us fucking howl laughing,
they just start doing stuff.
Think it's funny.
Here's the argument,
Joe,
don't you want it to be lady like she goes to middle school,
starts ripping fart.
She got the shitty girl and I wanted to be a nice person and I want him to be
whoever,
however she wants to be.
As long as she interacted with people would be ripping farts in school.
Listen Bro,
do you rip farts in school?
Come on.
Exactly right.
But when you were at your house and someone says,
all right,
well you can't rip those farts when you're in the teacher's office.
Okay,
do all you have to do is teach the kid went a fart and when not to Fart.
That's why I think also teaching them about swearing.
Like don't keep swearing from them.
Just tell them.
You will notice when daddy talks to the guy at the Lexus dealership,
notice how daddy doesn't use the word because you can't say,
come to the Lexus guy.
You know you gotta.
You gotta know when to be appropriate and when not to be appropriate but don't
because you don't want them figuring out through other people,
you know,
why should you hide anything from your kids if you think that it's okay to use
certain words,
you should use those words in front of kids,
but you should use them when you think they're able to discern when to and when
not to use them.
So I swear,
I've very rarely do I accidentally fuck up and swear in front of the kids.
So you try not to try.
Not to say,
but as time goes on I will absolutely start swearing.
Well,
not yet.
Not yet though.
That little ones in every now and then an accident.
No accident,
but sometimes not.
Sometimes.
Not on next.
What kind of swear word we talked to.
They're like occasional fuck.
And every now and then a shit that's not bad.
But even the fuck is cheese because they repeated it yet?
No,
no,
but the shit one when,
when the little one was three.
This was hilarious dude.
We were,
we were,
um,
we were skiing and uh,
we put all our stuff in the bag.
We were leaving and she forgot to pack her helmet and I go,
honey,
you forgot to put your helmet in there.
And she goes,
Shit,
my wife just bit her hand.
She turned away.
She didn't want to laugh.
And I went and I turned and looked away.
I'm like,
it was,
she didn't know how funny it was to her.
It was just a normal shit.
That's great.
But to hear it three year olds say,
ah,
what's weird is around my wife.
Uh,
he is,
she doesn't laugh,
she doesn't want to encourage like laughter.
She's trying to teach them to be proper but around me,
he knows
he could fart.
And I laughing and just me and him have far too far back and forth.
We're high fiving each other with foster moms around wearing the bathroom and
then he farts.
I got to hold it in and he's looking at me and I got to keep a straight face.
He's like,
don't throw me under the bus over here.
And I'm like,
I don't want to hear it from her.
And then she's looking at me knowing that I'm holding it in.
He feels so confident around me.
Like when when daddy's around he could just blow those.
So that's a problem that we're having.
We're having a.
that's so funny.
We're having a problem.
I think if you can hold them in,
it's like it's a nice thing to do.
It's hard enough holding my farts in.
It's hard enough holding my farts in around my wife.
I have to hold.
She,
she,
I don't want to fart around her.
She doesn't want me to start,
but I'm not going to hold my farts in around my son too.
That's like having two wives around my son.
He's going to get it.
I'm not holding shit and I'm going to blow his fucking ass around.
Another headline and the parts around son,
it's hard enough for the line.
Oh Dude.
Horror Gucci.
Just tag.
This is a great scrap man.
We're missing out on all the flights have been crazy.
They have.
We're just talking about foreign Dr Octopus for
headline.
And I said before this podcast that this podcast would not be a regular podcast,
but it kind of is.
It's not a fight companion podcast.
That's the big lie.
Were barely talking about fights people talk shit about,
but we haven't seen each other in a while.
Folks.
Fun
People do get mad,
but you don't have to listen for the most part.
It's all polished.
Chico caymus looks super good in this fight.
As those horror Gucci,
they're tagging each other out.
Harwood,
she's got that crazy wide stance.
Like what time is it over there in Japan right now?
11.
11 am started early for viewing pleasure dude.
Big right hand there by her Gucci.
This eliminate him now Eddie.
Something like that.
So it's probably,
it probably started at like nine or something.
If you're in those prelims,
you're waking up early.
Do you adjust?
You must adjust.
I'm like way in advance.
Your instagram,
you're doing Jujitsu at seven in the morning.
What the fuck's up with that?
So I roll man.
What time do you wake?
Really?
Just gets up at seven and takes a photo and puts it up the night before.
Yeah,
it's like seven in the morning.
I can't sleep.
I usually wake up already all night.
I usually wake up early.
You do Jujitsu at seven in the morning?
Yeah.
Jesus,
you're one of those dudes.
Got guys like that man.
I was letting your boy in a dozen.
Um,
your,
your boy down in San Diego.
Boogie Boogie.
Have a 6:00 AM six.
Switched it up though.
I think he,
I finally broke down and I think he doesn't do that anymore.
That's
6:00 AM Jiu Jitsu.
But there are people.
Thank God there are people like you.
I follow a on instagram.
Boogie woogie piano.
Got Shit.
I'm not trying to do too much shit at 7:00 AM,
but I liked that though.
Man.
I like to get a good workout in,
in the morning too.
I feel good.
What time do you wake up these days?
Depends if I have to take the kids to school,
you know,
it depends,
but a lot of times,
uh,
I,
I'll take,
I'll take like 8:00 Jujitsu,
8:00 yoga class really got.
I really want to start doing yoga,
man.
I'm being lazy when it comes to Yoga,
getting very close to being able to do Jujitsu again.
My shoulders not bothering me anymore.
I'm going to get another MRI to get it looked at,
but ever since the uh,
is this deontay wilder?
It's just the highlights is a fight over already.
Oh Wow.
They got fucked up.
Dude.
Was dancing big fucking black eyes,
man.
Look at his eyes.
Oh Shit.
Oh God.
Wow.
They're crack.
Oh my God.
He got cracked.
Do Crazy story.
He has a decision.
When was it a decision?
11th round.
Tko.
He stopped him in the 11th.
Round on taste for real fucking monster,
man.
I want to fight in that long.
I got recorded.
I'm going to see that.
I love watching them.
Wow.
He got a serious fucking black eye.
I fucked up.
I didn't want.
I didn't record it.
Goddammit.
Who?
I don't miss some NBC boxing.
Well,
wasn't there another fight on tonight?
Is near another,
another boxing match on tonight.
Is there something on Hbo Tonight as well?
Or is it just as much snow?
This was the big one.
Here's a great story though.
He's trained for like three years and that falls on the Olympic team.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
He's getting ready to all the time,
you know,
he was,
um,
it's really interesting.
It was one of the guys.
It was in line for Tyson fury,
Tyson fury.
They offered him this fight and instead he took the Vladimir Klitschko fight and
Vladimir fucked as Catholic now in public now is less bone now.
He's uh,
you know,
he shit out of luck,
but I think while they're smart,
you know,
not taking the fight with Klitschko yet,
he's not ready for it.
Well,
he's just,
you know,
he's getting ready and Klitschko is older unless he's doing drugs,
that's the thing.
And I'm not saying that he is,
but I'm not saying he isn't.
I agree.
He's 39 years old.
He looks fucking amazing and I just,
I don't know.
I don't know who's doing what.
You can't speculate,
but this is the reason for bringing it up though,
because if he is doing drugs,
he can keep that high level for a much longer time.
Especially at heavyweight.
Yeah.
If he's not doing drugs,
you got to wonder how much time he has left.
Thirty nine years of age.
The wheels can fall off at any moment.
He'll make you guys hundreds of fights.
You have to think about his amateur career and this procreate.
I think he's 63 and three or some shit like that.
Well,
his brother was a competitive kickboxer and I think he was too.
I want to say he wasn't.
It was just kicked.
No kickboxing,
kill his brother.
Fought PKA karate style above the waist.
Kickbox cheese with the crazy long pants on.
He must have been a motherfucker.
Yeah,
he was a bad motherfucker.
He actually got knocked out in kickboxing and like that PKA karate style.
I forget who he fought.
He fought.
Some guy was.
I feel like he got knocked out by a kick look up.
Vitali Klitschko gets.
Dude.
I,
I love watching the political fight.
Don't miss one.
He was an animal man when he was at his best.
I watched the Shannon breaks fight the other day.
Him and Shannon breaks.
What a war.
Jesus Christ.
You guys keep up with boxing and UFC.
Shannon's great.
Right?
You know,
we talked about,
I talked about Shannon Briggs on the podcast recently and she had briggs,
uh,
went back and forth with him on instagram now about what?
A couple of times because he's,
he's awesome man.
He's every video he does.
He,
uh,
he would.
Is this a Klitschko gets knocked out.
A Shannon breaks,
has these motivational videos on instagram.
You got to follow his instagram because he's,
he's always like,
let's go champ.
Let's go chill and talk and shit.
The Vladimir
Vladimir,
but talking positive shit like,
come out champ.
You've got to put away them sodas,
champ.
You've got to drink water champ.
You've got to be healthy champion to get up early champ.
Can't be staying out late.
Partying champ.
And everything is like,
let's go champ champ.
Oh,
it's great.
It's hilarious.
But he's funny when he does it too,
like he's laughing and cracking jokes.
But uh,
we'll see the cat trying to get the fight with Vladimir.
And he was like,
yeah,
he was on the boat where you can chat and you eat.
I eat his food.
Yeah,
man.
Vladimir through some water on him.
Always trying to hype up a fight,
man.
It just never happened.
Well,
it might happen now.
It might happen now.
You think?
Yes,
it's very possible.
It'll happen now because a briggs,
just one.
He just knocked out,
uh,
his opponent I want to say in the second round.
But you look real good dude.
I mean,
I don't know who the dude was that he fought,
but he looks sharp and it was impressive and he's got a big following on social
media.
Like a lot of like snoop dogg made this video where he was smoking weed and a
snoop was like,
take a big puffs.
Let's go chance.
I'm flexible,
champ,
champ.
I'm smoking this joyful you champ.
It's hilarious getting that support.
Well he's,
he's like,
it's super positive,
like all the stuff that he does,
it's very positive.
You see that snoop dogg video with the little dicky ever heard of the Little
Dicky?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
the white guy.
The Jewish rapper.
Yeah.
He's great at that song.
Saved that money.
Okay.
And then he,
he did a song.
He's got a bunch of songs.
He's Ah,
he's incredible.
He's been around forever,
but he did a song with snoop Dogg and there's a cartoon that goes along with it
fucking incredible.
It's called professional rapper.
Holy fucking shit.
Him and snoop Dogg or going back and forth.
Really?
Oh,
he's trying to get,
trying to get snoop Dogg to sign them as soups all.
Why should I sign you and,
and dude,
it's,
it's one of the most brilliant rap songs ever,
man.
Funny as shit.
That's high praise and Bravo.
Yeah,
I did it.
I was completely floored.
Jamie Little Dicky.
Cut to the cut to the Kale here.
We're for the 15 minute videos to guys and long pants and shitty kicks.
God Damn not looking at it,
but the dude who was the heritage you've got.
We'll kicked in the mug.
So really to set up again.
See,
that was Klitschko.
Boom.
Yep.
That was vitaly.
He got.
We'll kicked in the head back it up a little bit further than that,
that he started doing current contact karate or kickboxing.
And this dude.
No,
no,
no ring,
but it was above the waist.
Kickbox and with the dude starts getting loose with his kicks.
That was nasty.
That was nice.
What ma'am?
I mean,
shit happens.
Yeah.
Well anybody who gets hit by that is fucked.
I mean he's sitting his head up.
How long ago was that?
A long time ago by that video.
Fucking 1987.
It was a long time ago.
Goodyear?
I think vitaly is older than the black on the bottom and shit,
but tallies like a couple of years older and Vladimir is 39 so that could have
been from 90 to 90.
There you go.
That makes sense.
People are just figuring out Moitai back then
they didn't know.
They didn't know that,
that no,
kicking to the legs is just stupid as fuck.
I took a few guys going over to Thailand.
Took like a.
When Rick,
the Jack Rufus.
Who the fuck did he fight?
Fought some real high level Thai guy.
Had they got hurt real bad and he was laying the ground level as record was not
impressive at all.
How the roof is fog.
Yeah.
He may have been famous legend and all that,
but looking at his record,
he was like 13 and six or something like,
Oh really?
And Yeah.
Yeah,
that's crazy match.
It was one of the first fights we ever got to see a guy who really knew how to
throw a leg kicks though.
Fucked his legs up.
They fucked his legs up,
but it was interesting.
I liked kicks in.
They had to put him in a stretcher in a stretcher because he couldn't walk and
Duke who's getting it gets interviewed after the fight was like,
well,
not a lot of skill involved in that.
Didn't know any better because now he's like one of the best Moitai for mma
coaches in the country.
It's hilarious.
He watched that when his brother got his legs kicked.
Alec.
We didn't know that.
No one knew.
Then when I first,
when I first saw UFC too,
I was blown away by horse.
I was doing karate at the time and to me I was thinking this is probably just
primitive as wrestling.
It looks,
it looks like a real wrestler with fuck him up,
but then I went in and got choked out 37 times and realized,
Oh shit,
it's not primitive wrestling.
It's highly advanced wrestling.
I had three big steps in like from going from taekwondo,
like I,
I thought that taekwondo was like the best way to fight stand up until I started
kickboxing and I started boxing,
just straight boxing with people to get better kickboxing and then I realized
man,
like my boxing is so far behind these guys and I thought my hands were so much
better than they were,
but at least I have kicks.
And then I started sparring with this kid,
this kid named Dana Rosenblatt and went on to be like New England middle weight
boxing champion.
Very good box or slot on Tuesday night fights a bunch.
Yeah.
You were boxing with them?
Yeah,
yeah.
We did some kickboxing to,
but we did a lot of only boxing,
but the point is he had a friend that was fighting in Thailand.
He had this friend that was crazy.
It would go over to Thailand and fight,
fight the ties and he was just,
he was a real pioneer.
This dude is like one of
the first Americans to start going over their training in Thailand and fighting
tyler.
We hadn't really heard about it then and so Dana and I were going over some of
the techniques that we're talking about,
some of it and we were talking about like the elbows and the kicks and we were
practicing some of it and just him hitting me half assed on the leg,
like not trying to hurt me,
just him throwing a leg kick and feeling the Shin slamming on my leg.
Just like that.
Just thump.
I remember thinking,
oh no,
like,
like this is all missing.
I didn't know about this.
Like how do I not know about this?
Like this is critical.
And then the,
the clenching and the knees to the body.
And then the elbows from the clinch.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
like there's a giant hole missing in all of the standup.
And then,
you know,
it never really took off because of that PKA karate shit.
You know,
the PKA karate Kinda like spoiled people to the idea of a,
of kickboxing.
I think that,
like Dana White said that,
I think he's right,
man.
I think like a lot of people in this country that are like in our forties,
I mean we look back on that stuff on TV.
If you don't study martial arts,
you think of kickboxing is like bad.
Brad Half-ton,
like with the shiny red shorts throwing like as many they have to show,
like throw like six kicks around.
Otherwise they lose points.
Remember that say would throw these little flippy kicks and they would get in
there with some sloppy boxing.
So it was like flippy kicks and sloppy boxing and nobody wanted to watch it.
It just wasn't that good.
It wasn't that evolved.
Tila Rick roofers came along and a few guys came along that we were like real
dynamic,
but it's never really caught on,
was still has it,
right.
Like kickboxing here,
which I don't get like k one like glory or even what did,
uh,
what did belt or put on,
what was that they put on something called dynamite.
That was part kickboxing and part of MMA.
But here's,
here's what I think though,
man.
I think kickboxing dope and I liked watching it,
but you know,
what's better?
Moitai more ties better,
you know,
because it's,
it's the full fucking arsenal of punching,
kicking elbows and knees.
And the clinch.
I watched,
uh,
the lion fight.
There was this past weekend.
I enjoyed they shit out of it,
dude.
The first dream killer Delano's.
Did you see that fucking spinning elbow?
He knocked that to that with no.
My God,
who was two spinning elbow Kaos like,
dude,
elbows are big man.
It's a weapon of boy ty.
I don't think there's any reason to take that out.
I don't think there's any reason to take elbows out.
I think if organizations like glory and those guys want to just kick box,
let them just kickbox but let do the elbow man.
Let them throw them away.
I don't think so.
I don't know what they're worried about.
But are those shows
successful?
I mean,
what's an access?
TV has a limited exposure.
There's not as many households that have access.
TV used to be like it does well though,
Gloria doesn't do that well.
It doesn't do as well as it probably could for whatever reason.
People don't know who these fighters are yet.
They don't.
It's not like something that people have been accustomed to get your site kit,
but watching the fucking the boy tie on access TV.
Dude,
I love it.
Nasty.
And this Guy Joe,
not a want.
If you've seen him.
Twenty five year old Thai guy,
nasty fucking kicker,
dude.
One of the nastiest kickers I've ever seen.
The dude just throws,
throws,
punches to close the distance like his hands are up.
Way High,
brutal left kick left,
kick to the body lift kit.
This chopping this dude down.
And then once he gets close in on he,
he finishes them with actually two elbows to the back of the head.
Fuck.
He blasted him with one elbow and then as the guys going down,
he just fucking Tomahawks the back of his neck.
I Wa,
I,
I record the,
those lion fights.
I watched the first one when I was like two and one.
We're going to think it was pro debut and they fucking went at it.
If you've got some Cli,
you see Yonson Clive.
No.
Holy Shit Dude.
There's the lion fight is getting these guys from Thailand that are super high
level tie fighters and you're seeing some wild wild fights because of how much
of those guys online flight makes.
No,
that's good.
Does anyone know?
Someone asked me last night and I said,
I don't know,
fucking $500.
I think the the,
the,
the guy who was making his debut as like maybe a thousand.
I was trying to think back to my debut in mma or maybe a thousand dollars.
I get paid $800.
I think it's the most under appreciated thing going on right now.
Lion fight.
I really do.
Those fucking fights are super high level entertainment.
Super exciting.
Super entertaining,
wild wild shit.
People getting dropped all my drawing.
They're getting knocked the fuck out to just figuring out how to make kickboxing
entertainment.
Well,
it is more tie.
It's not just the.
I think there's a part.
The part of the problem with kickboxing is you're,
you're able to do this,
you're able to do that.
Alistair overeem with gloves that come up real high and you just wait in and
then they throw kicks and punches to kind of trade.
Right?
Sometimes they do and it's look at the highest levels.
Like when you're watching guys like Nikki whole skin and his mother
motherfuckers.
I mean it's fun to watch at the,
at the highest level,
no doubt,
but I think you should have the other elements.
I think if it's a standup fight,
those other.
If you can share a guy across the head.
Okay.
Can you share a guy across the head?
It's legal.
Okay.
There's no shin pads.
All right,
so why can't you elbow anything triggered why?
Why nothing is more dangerous than.
Exactly.
So what are we doing here?
What you limiting weapons?
Why would you limit weapons and stand up?
If you limit weapons and stand up,
then you get an unrealistic sense of the,
the development of kickboxing technique,
the development of MMA as far as like stand up striking you because like the
guys at the highest level,
if you see a guy like Kevin Bras are like one of these like super high level
kickboxer guys and you see like that,
that becomes like a standard and then that standard goes into like an 11 or a
Joe Schilling.
He see that high standard of style of kickboxing and that becomes the.
The guys who were fighting in mma aspire to that level.
True.
Like in the higher the level is and kickboxing and the higher the level is going
to be an mma as well I think.
But as soon as you limit certain techniques that you say,
well,
they can't throw elbows and they can't throw nice,
well then the,
then you're going to get a distorted perception of it in mma because in mma you
can do those things.
So what's shut like what's the reason
for the.
They got everything.
This guy was right here.
They would say it's because,
hey,
one,
that's okay.
One did it.
That's what the Japanese did.
What did they.
What did they followed?
Suit.
What do they think?
I don't know.
They're doing it for a reason.
The Japanese do shit for a reason.
I think they think it's more exciting.
I think the by taking away the clinch,
you make guys fight more.
You know you may not make them.
They can't clench up as much because if you watch Moitai,
a lot of it takes in the clench.
They throw nasty elbows to the,
to the body.
A lot of sweeps.
They trip each other because Barbara,
I don't mean to cut you off,
do anything.
It's gives the barbaric to like with the elbows don't know,
especially with the American.
Why have it in MMA made?
Then why is it not?
My may can kick someone in the head.
Everything's an MMA.
The standup wise that's in Moitai everything I'm thinking on the ground while on
the sit on the ground.
There's that one dumb rule.
That's it.
That rule so dumb,
but that's it.
The 1:12 to six elbow rule.
The rule is ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense if the rule,
if you don't know what it is,
you can't go down from like on the clock from 12:00 to 6:00 with an elbow.
He gets too dangerous.
It's only because the people that were in the athletic commission had seen a guy
break a brick with that.
I saw that.
No,
you can't hit someone in the head.
They could die.
No.
Twelve to six elbows.
So you can't even do it to a thigh.
Which is hilarious.
Did you see that homewood?
That boxer in Australia died.
Who?
Some,
a god,
he was a whatever.
He had like 30 something fights.
He died and he got knocked out.
Didn't wake up.
They took him to the hospital.
He died in the room.
Yeah.
It's like the one that happened two or three times a year.
No,
I don't think so.
It happens every now and then.
This was the last one.
So in tweet it to me,
I thought they took the t two.
I thought you looked at it.
I might have.
Um,
it just happens,
you know,
it's,
it's a part of boxing,
so it's a scary part of boxing.
Bobby Ray's ex got this documentary on Gerald McClellan.
He did a little dark on them.
That's a crazy story,
man.
Yeah.
I saw that fight live,
not live TV.
Nigel Benn and Gerald McClellan.
Asher,
that fight,
you know,
Gerald Mcclellan knows he was awesome.
Yeah.
At one point in time he was one of the scariest boxers alive and he was a.
They were thinking that he would be next in line fight.
Roy Jones,
they were looking at Roy Johnson.
Roy Jones was coming up and after he'd beaten James,
Tony and Gerald Mcclellan was the destroyer just smashing everybody.
But he used to cut a lot of weight.
Man,
he cut a lot of weight and I'm back in those days.
I think you had a way in the day of the fight I think you would.
And they didn't know anything about Ivs.
They didn't know anything about that shit.
And when you do that,
you,
you your brain man,
you just do that.
No.
Wicki guy was on here and he was saying that they think it might take more than
70 hours to 72 hours,
72 hours for your brain to completely recover from being dehydrated like that.
And the crazy thing is most of the deaths in boxing or in the lower weight
classes,
they're not in a heavyweight where the guys punched the hardest.
It's in the lower weight classes and they think it's because of dehydration.
They think that's a significant factor and a lot of these guys dying and
hemorrhaging,
getting brain hemorrhages in the ring and dying,
they think dehydration is a significant factor.
So homeboy died.
Well Gerald Mcclellan didn't die,
but he,
he,
he.
But he was a superstar.
He was a superstar.
He was a world champion.
He was on the rise and he,
he hurt Nigel Benn bad knock them through the ropes.
But Nigel Benn was a bad motherfucker.
Been thought with an Afro Sheen.
Yeah.
Well you had dreadlocks.
He crazy dreadlocks and Nigel bank got back in that ring and it was fucking
slinging.
And they,
uh,
they clashed heads and Gerald Mcclellan went down and um,
I think that was when he went to his corner and he just stopped the fight.
I think it was right after a head clash.
But I think he had,
he had been hit a couple times.
Nigel Bennett tagged him.
I mean they were,
they were teen off in each other and then there was a big collision of heads and
Gerald took a knee,
I think and stay down for the count of Eight.
And then I think never got up.
I think sat on a stool and then collapsed.
Pretty sure that's how it went.
He didn't die,
but why the fuck would they make a documentary?
Because he's,
he's almost blind from that.
He's dying.
He can't talk.
He barely,
barely remembers anything about his career.
He's been taken care of by sisters.
His body's completely atrophied and it's really sad to see you man.
And if you go back before that fight,
he was the motherfucker,
you know,
he was like one of those guys like Gennady Golovkin or something like that.
They'll financially.
No,
I don't think so,
man.
I know I'm obviously a joke joke.
How dare you?
That's a bummer.
I think Roy Jones done some stuff to help,
but uh,
apparently,
uh,
a lot of people think that that was what had fucked Roy Jones up earlier in his
career and made them place safe.
Here's a hall is about to fight gay garden was shit.
Eddie,
you got your IRA?
No,
no,
no.
I got massage,
but was saucy.
Very confident that I know yet.
Sauces.
Pressuring him real early,
man.
Not Scared.
She's so he gets them down early.
Oh yeah.
This one is not gonna last.
It's hard to keep them.
Oh Man.
It hurt them to tag them with a right hand in the ground.
And pound was saucy all over Uriah Hall.
Mother Fucker,
man.
What are the arm bars?
Oh,
Jesus.
Big left hand.
Jesus Christ with sauces all over him.
Super aggressive sauces.
Got some nasty ground pound.
I don't know how good.
Uriah Hall's guard is a good guard.
You got to have a good garden.
Whose House has got high level ground game,
man.
You're A.
Yeah.
If there's a knock on your eyes to the ground game,
oh shit.
Can't teed off on.
These are dangerous.
Exactly how.
How you fight your.
I have though,
a lot of pressure.
Don't let them sit back and guard a lot detail.
No,
not from what I saw.
Who's his main trainer right now is it's the guy who was trained in jail,
right?
Yeah.
That black guy.
What is his name?
I forget.
Racist.
Look at that.
We just said
it's about the crucifix and go to work with elbows.
Ever going to stop it too much for him.
Oh man,
you're right.
You're right.
You gotta
gotTa frame up.
But I left home and I said,
why don't you fly out?
It keeps it fresh.
Look at that.
Look at that crash.
Such a smart fighter man.
You look at the guys he's beat jock.
Re.
Hector,
lumbar.
I mean Henderson such a list.
That big house to the elbow.
Oh Jesus Christ.
His ground and pounds.
Fucking ferocious and it's intelligent to.
He does a real good job.
That was a big elbow.
The amount of shots that he gets in versus attempted is very high.
He's going to break you.
He knows when he can tee off on you and when he can't.
If you look at is percentage of landing ground and pound strikes is pretty high.
They're the arm shouldn't as you ride hall know to hold onto that garden
and he's had.
He's fine.
Yeah,
he's fine.
He's fine.
Right or left hand.
But you know what back?
No.
Get this crucifix.
Crucifix.
I man left leg trapped.
Look this,
you can still explode a little.
You could explode a little,
but he doesn't have the confidence to try to get up.
Now he's going to be worn out.
He's got this case.
It's got half guard and double under hooks,
right?
This just doesn't have that to get up and reverse.
Have Garden.
It is the other side.
Hang onto that headset.
Isn't that Funny Eddie?
Like he would have to have his head on the right hand side for it to be more
effective on his right hand.
So he has geico.
Tell you what,
that's a long flight back home to the US from
looking nice and attacks with a leg.
That was a very nice mountain scape and this is some good swamp walking by.
I know you're at home in his Jujitsu,
Jason.
Mainly.
Who's a fucking monster legged monster.
Really?
Well,
that's not bad right there.
At least not good.
Attempting to get out of that position.
Yeah,
at least he got out of the mouth
and there's hope now was trying to go for the leg again.
He's just way,
way Manley's shallow though.
He has to let go,
but it's going to give up his back and going for it and he's.
He's gone back to it back in his guard again though.
We'll kick hard.
Smart.
He just did.
He didn't play the game right there.
He just said,
I just went up and you've already got your smart and he knows how to pass.
Okay.
To mention a good.
That's not a good defense of the past either by your ride.
He doesn't have it.
Turns it around.
Oh my goodness.
Holy Shit.
That was Jason Manly Shit,
man.
I'm telling you this,
Jason man must know because the way he did it from having no fucking control the
legs at all,
that's what Jason teaches.
But isn't that like a classic defence?
Jason Manley's really good at rolling.
So
to cameras,
that's the classic,
right?
The overcommitment for the Camorra and then there's a spinning pharcyde arm bar
counter.
That's so good at St Pierre.
Matt.
He right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but he,
he,
he initiated the Camorra.
Uriah Hall.
Thought about spinning it on him,
but he spun back on
this back control 45 seconds to go.
Not good for you.
This is the thing on this position,
if you want to take away his explosiveness is doing it.
It is.
Let's see how good his defenses from here because gate guard doesn't have there.
It goes by the triangle.
Now wear him out with that for awhile.
You know,
he's got to get them down again.
I mean this is going to be over.
He's going to survive.
Kenny,
take him down again.
He took them down pretty easily.
He's got it.
He's got it locked in there.
He's got a lot of
the other
second load of the sleep thing.
I don't want them to tap me neither.
I want the skin.
Once he got it,
he got to ride.
Let him break it.
Go.
Ooh.
Oh,
how?
How great is a fight when you want to see the you.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
But that was.
It came out like a motherfucker slick.
Written naked man.
Very slick.
Look,
I could.
You know.
What?
Is it funny that they have this commercial was fucking monster from the swamp.
The cracking or something kills these dudes.
How much different is that than an alligator?
They see those bitches all the time.
Alligator.
Stupid as fuck.
They see that scary when they're smart.
Nothing scarier than octopuses.
That's true.
A B movie right there.
No street octopus movie that comes out of the water that can come out at night.
They could stay on for 30 minutes.
I saw some.
I saw some gnarliest crocodiles in Costa Rica.
Man,
raining.
Oh Shit.
At the training.
That giant killer octopus could fucking track you down up the mountains.
Can Hide in trees and shit with you.
About that,
do you ever see the octopus that climbs out of the fish tank and goes across the
floor?
It happens on a million videos on youtube.
Do you do?
It's incredible how many octopus videos they're on.
You too,
baby brown too.
So here's the question.
I'm the first round clear to gay guard,
right?
Total control.
But uriah,
I mean,
can you take him down again?
Take them down.
He's going to be hesitant.
You know Chael Sonnen took Anderson.
Oh shit son.
Those.
Stop it.
Don't stop it yet.
No,
no,
no.
It started with a guard.
He's getting smashed.
Stop it now.
You got to stop it.
Oh my
God.
See,
this is what I was saying before,
the fight that this guy has moments where his hand got you in that discussion.
So extraordinary.
You were saying like the best things you were.
You were saying all the right things,
but meanwhile you right in the first round and the first round,
you were perfectly right.
He really did what you,
you would do in the
first round.
Anderson's jail son and took Anderson Silva down.
The first reading was all over him and I thought,
man,
he's not.
Can he do that for five rounds?
Well,
here's,
here's the thing.
I mean,
could you Ryan Hall have the explosiveness left in that second round of getting
mauled in the first to look at this.
Kicked to the fucking mom.
Come on,
man.
What I'm saying about,
look at that movement with.
They're probably going to show one more time,
but look how there's no fat in that movement.
The way he throws this.
Watch this look,
dude,
you don't see that comment.
There's no,
no give can't train for them.
No.
Well you can.
You can train to never be close doing signings.
Tough shit is so good,
dude.
That'll be a highlight.
Both of those
are legit stoppage,
man.
This is a legit stoppage.
You know?
I mean,
I know Musashi would probably say it's not fair.
You got to.
You got to give it to a man by a holy
shit.
See,
that's kind of what I meant.
Kind of what I meant when,
when I'm talking about what he can do in moment,
which is exactly what I'm.
Well,
if,
if you,
if your eye gets off season of confidence from this,
good luck.
The next guy fights with Brendan.
I go,
if I'm like Brendan's making all the valid points here,
but you are right.
We were both wrong.
But meanwhile he did threaten off his back in the first round with that arm bar.
So you know that he is working on his Jujitsu.
He's 100 percent working on his Jujitsu because that was pretty slick.
The way set that up and he caught me off guard was a high level of coach to
Jason Bailey is a monster.
Well I've been around guys like that before.
The,
these guys who could pull off those wild spinning techniques like from the
taekwondo days and I know like what a high level looks like and his is a super
high level man and he's,
he's just so physically sharp.
Like he's so fast.
Like once he gets the technique down and he obviously has it down perfect,
it's,
he can pull the trigger faster than almost anybody you're gonna bring into
interstate.
There's really only one knock on your right.
It's always been his mental state and not a win over Musashi's fucking enormous
giant and it's just a stoppage when jump spinning,
especially after coming back for that first round,
right,
got destroyed.
Couldn't go down because of the mess.
Again.
The mental game can come from experience because I remember Gary Goodrich back
when he first started fighting.
He tapped his first,
last or second last.
He would tap really quick just from the stinging of the punches on the ground.
People were tapped to the stinging,
but then by the end of his career he was kickboxing.
K One taken full blown and he learned to survive and take those shots.
Yeah.
No,
he did and get,
you know,
Gary went on to fight some serious fucking contenders in k one.
He fought some high level guys in k one and an MMA to man.
Gary fought a lot of crazy fights.
Can we please see Uriah Hall
and Leo Machida next or what?
Joe Silva.
Your willpower.
Uriah hall versus Michael Bisping.
How about that?
Bisping has a fight against whitaker and then Anderson said,
well,
wants to fight them after that.
I can't see whitaker,
whitaker in Australia.
Oh,
we used to fight at one 71.
Thanks.
So now he's going to fight it in Australia.
Brisbane is on the card.
That's interesting.
Interesting.
Right?
Weird fight for who's with [inaudible].
Last two.
He got stopped by someone who was like a really good striker.
Who.
What was that?
Robert Winter cruise record,
but that's a.
it's a.
it's a win.
Bids and told me that we're on set and he told me that went.
That's an instinct fight for you.
Big,
big,
big fucking wind for Uriah Hall.
Doesn't get much bigger than that.
Number six in the world.
He'll put you right in the top.
Ten makes Joe Rogan look like he knows what the fuck he's talking about.
Oh Shit.
Whitaker lost a ton of Stephen Thompson.
That's the guy.
Wonderboy.
He's another one.
He has this.
When when he got more and more comfortable with takedown defense and grappling,
he spent so much time with Weidman working on his wrestling.
Then you got to see it in the ellenberger fight.
You got to see what I'm mother get confident because they don't.
They're not worried if the fight goes down there and exactly if it does go down
and I'm all right,
well they know that they can defend and I also know when there are,
when they are standing,
you can't fuck with wonderboy,
dude.
You gotta no one can.
It's also a different style because like,
just like your Ryan Hall,
your Bio Hall has more of a karate style that he does a Thai style.
Like when he throws her leg kicks and stuff,
when he throws round kicks,
he throws them like without like the wind up so they land quicker.
Does not as much.
Like a lot of the Thai guys,
they're doing these steps and everything is coming round.
They're chopping,
but everything's coming round your riots throwing shit.
You,
you don't.
If you don't train with a guy like that,
you don't know those,
those movements,
you don't know,
Oh,
if I'm standing this close to him,
he can jump spinning back,
kick him in the face.
You're not training with that.
I can get away from him.
Bill machita effect.
When machita first came on and guys were like,
what the fuck?
He can do more though.
Machida never did this,
but she didn't never did that.
He never did that in a fight like a horse kicked machida would throw round kicks
and knees and punches and he did that jumping front kick to random.
I'm saying at the time we did that,
people haven't seen it move in and out and guys couldn't get the distance and
they get knocked out.
That's true.
I think gay guy thought he was safe and then the eight a fucking healed of the
face.
Dude.
I mean that,
that,
that kind of speed from that distance and the way he does it with no wind up,
man.
He's a crazy athlete.
There's no telegraphing it.
It's he's a great athlete,
but it's also intelligent preparation.
True.
Because to train someone to throw those things on a trigger like that with no
wind up at all,
like that's the.
That's the ultimate goal is to have an athlete who's a really good athlete who
also listens and trains intelligently to the point where there's no wind up.
He just jumps and kicks.
God Damn.
What a win.
What a fucking
wind for him.
Eddie could have made your money.
Tiger Schulman guy.
Is that where he started?
Yes.
Is this amazing?
And his second degree.
Black Belt,
right?
I think so.
You know what's amazing?
Like Tiger Schulman was like play.
I'm looking at Jesus,
Dr. Don.
Just beautiful.
And then this nasty.
I think Musashi might've thought it was a wheel kick.
Instead he hit him with that jumped spinning back,
kick to the face.
God,
look at this.
Oh my goodness.
That is insane.
Oh my time timing this how people expected you had to fight coming off the
ultimate fighter.
He lost that one slide.
There's a little bit of let down and he's just doing work and their mindset
Palae.
Well,
you know what man,
if a fucking fight went the way the first round went,
you wouldn't be saying this.
Which is what's amazing.
You know like you were right and I was right.
We were both right,
but he figured it out.
He figured it out.
They made adjustments.
Good luck.
Whoever fights him next.
Well,
he's going to learn from that first round to that.
That could happen to him in the grappling.
She's going to have to concentrate on his grappling even more.
It's going to have to bring it up to another,
but he knows he survived and using some dangerous shit mounted.
He almost control.
I mean,
how close did he come to tap and dry?
A rear naked.
That was close.
I think about that.
It makes the victory even sweeter.
It's an amazing win.
How about this fight?
This is not just DC verse.
It's a very interesting thing to enter.
You know,
you wonder what,
what Gustafson can do on the feet,
you know,
like can he keep dc off of them?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Can You keep the fight standing?
Does he try to take dc down the way he tried to take John Down.
Does he try to,
to,
to let them know really early on.
Hey,
I can take you down to.
Does he try to do what?
What Jones did take in DC down?
That's not happening.
You would say that,
but right.
You would take Jones down either took him down twice different though.
Well also you got to think it took dc down the,
but the word was that John did not take the Gustafson fight very seriously and
training.
That's what I've heard.
That is the.
That is the world.
We're not lying about that.
Whether or not that would have played a factor with Annette Gustafson would've
have been able to take them down anyway.
We don't know.
I feel like this fight thinking enough hype,
getting no hype,
zero hype.
I haven't heard anybody talk about it because John Jones is right there.
So elephant in the room.
Will John be both of them?
So it's like,
all right,
well there you go.
And he said he just nailed it.
That's exactly what it is.
Zero hype.
I mean John is just so everybody knows.
He's so good.
He's so special.
And that's also what's tragic about it.
You know when a great comeback story though.
Amazing.
If he could pull it off.
It's amazing.
Josh Barnett,
them triathlon runner,
look at their records.
Just a ton of fight.
Josh Barnett look leaner than I've ever seen him ever.
So the best shape I've ever seen him.
How much did he weigh?
Good question.
He still has to be 50 you think forties?
For sure.
He's a bad boy.
What's the guests?
How much Josh Barnett?
If he was
to 40 to 45,
I'll say 48 to 48.
Can we find out and say we'll find down here?
40th five.
It was the same.
We need the official.
Wayne's not the old one.
Yeah.
The,
the problem is they,
a lot of times when they,
like when I read these things off,
uh,
at the fights,
like they have a uh,
a tale of the tape.
Maybe we go to the video of the wind.
It's got to be there.
But what I'm saying is for heavyweights,
the only way you uh,
you hear it as if like Bruce buffer sandy correctly.
Thirty nine because like sometimes on my sheet that I'll get like say,
you know,
I get a sheet from the UFC that shows a fighters record and I'll get the weight
that they use to weigh in other fights.
Sometimes there'll be heavier or lighter.
So what does it says?
Two 39.
Whoa.
Nelson to 69.
So he was over by four pounds.
I forgot he Barnett was 2:39 who said 2:39.
Powerful Jamie.
Nailed it.
Uh,
hold up.
He can't be two,
six and a handle.
Otherwise the appellant is right.
Must have had to either give up 20 percent of his purse or lose the weight.
The hold up bro got fatter.
Maybe he lost the weight.
Wouldn't be hard,
right?
I don't know Bro.
He probably was shocked that Uriah Hall flooded.
I still can't get over this.
Fucking amazing.
Yeah.
And it was.
We were saying this,
he can do some shit,
man,
that guys can do.
And I knew guys like that.
I knew a lot of guys like that from my a taekwondo days.
There was guys that just had this ability to explode with,
uh,
with lightening fast spinning techniques that if you weren't ready for it,
do you got lit up?
You got fucked up a fucking rothwell and a steep air fighting real soon.
Right?
That's a great fight.
There was this kid that I said,
no,
his name is Larry Jones.
And his legs went all the way up to his ribs.
His hips like started here.
He was a tall dude.
He was like six foot three,
maybe somewhere around then.
But his legs were like way longer than he was tired.
He looked like the monster.
He had legs that were perfectly designed for kicking you.
And this guy,
when I wouldn't talk about like talented dudes,
like physically talented dudes who could throw kicks that no one saw coming.
I used to watch this guy kick like the bag and I would just be marveled,
just like marbled look.
I couldn't believe what he could do with his legs.
He would throw these front leg side kick that which has been this bag in half
because he was a big dude.
You know,
Larry was probably like 220 natural pounds,
six with three lien.
Didn't lift any weights,
built for kicking bail for kicking.
Like his,
all of his weight.
I mean it might,
might not have been even that heavy.
It might've been like 200 pounds now that I think about it.
But he wasn't a weight lifter at all.
Like it was all just throwing kicks and running up hills and shit like that.
But he would,
he would kick the bag and you just go,
what the fuck man?
Like you'd never seen anything like
it.
He would throw these spinning techniques.
And ever since that I was like,
well,
how come I haven't seen a guy who couldn't move like that in mma?
And then you start slowly seemed like Barboza can do it,
you know,
a few other guys could do it.
They can move like that with that kind of speed and their spins.
Barboza has the quickest kicks I've ever seen in my life.
Never,
never seen anybody quick.
Does he have a fight scheduled hopes?
I don't think so.
I was telling Michael Jai White,
you know,
his big giant karate guy.
I was,
I was just telling him about Joe Rogan's turn inside kicks and all the stories
and all that shit.
And he's at my gym.
He's big.
He's like six foot four,
240 pounds.
Did Karate his whole life and shit.
And I'm telling,
telling them about Joe Rogan's turning psychic,
how amazing it is.
And he goes,
okay,
let that go.
Let me see you.
Let me.
Let me see you throw one.
So he throws one.
After all the Shit I've talked about,
Joe at legends were Tenth Planet Headquarters used to be.
He fucking throws one turn inside.
Kik breaks the bag off your breaks it all the psyllium lands.
I'm like,
oh shit,
Chris Riley's going to be fucking pissed.
We're trying to put it back up.
I'm holding the backup.
It's like the chain totally broke off.
And then we just left it on the,
on the ground as a ground and pound a bag.
But kinda like,
I couldn't say anything about Joe Rogan anymore.
I'm like,
this motherfucker just broke.
Michael.
Shy White is an athlete too.
He has his clean
fuck.
He's got clean karate technique man.
And he,
he,
I think he hopping side kicked it right inside the blue.
The bag off the ceiling.
Yeah.
They weren't very good at keeping those bags on the ceiling.
I broke that chain that
I was telling you about the video with GSP and going to block.
That was a different bag though.
Remember that was a center bag and the GSP bag as a bar back to the far right.
A couple people broke that back,
but you got to be a motherfucker to break that pack that Shane was like really?
Chintzy.
Oh,
okay.
But when he hit it,
he hit it perfect.
No,
but I've seen him do a lot of other stuff too.
I've seen him throw a lot of kicks.
He Kicks Holy Shit.
Real
well.
He's,
you know,
he's a super athlete.
Like when you watch Michael Jai white in movies,
like watch them and do all that stuff.
And movies like that guy could do that shit for real.
What's he do now?
He makes movies,
TV shows and Shit.
He's always doing something.
I saw.
I'm always staying.
I coordinated some fights for never backed down to somebody his bike.
He wanted some high level Jujitsu in there.
And if you've got it,
have you watched her back down to do these twists during and Crotch or ripping
people?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I forgot when you guys went down there for the crazy.
How,
how quickly and on the spot those fights.
Uh,
uh,
get put together because we're just on the set figuring it out.
We're like,
okay,
this next flight we need to.
We have like a basic idea that we go over like three times and we just start
filming.
I'll just,
the I've ever seen Roy.
He's preached Bonnie Lens.
That ain't good.
God is good.
Our guts on.
I don't know.
It might be.
Maybe not though,
right?
Oh my God.
If I lose this one,
that's $2,000 spent on Roy.
Did you bet on?
No,
no,
no.
But it seems like a short bat.
But anything that happens,
no shorts,
no shirt.
But yes.
When a do punches as hard as roy does,
fucking never.
No ma'am.
I just think Barnett's gonna close the distance.
Drag them to the Mat and do work.
Michael.
Jai White is a black belt and kill Christian.
The journey to zero begins now.
Bring it.
You know,
John Wayne has done that.
You have to spar like multiple people in a day.
He's done those,
those crazy killed Christian competitions where you know,
like to get your black publish,
something like that.
They may fight like fucking 10 different talks about that on my podcast.
30 guys in one day.
That's real.
They'll will make you spar like 30 guys,
like each guy has a few minutes.
It was
so fast and so strong.
I'm sure there is no problem for him.
He's a weird style too because they,
uh,
they punched full blast to the body and then they kick full blast of the head
and they stand right in front of each other and they don't wear any pants.
So there's like,
there's a lot of like,
you can't go nowhere or punched,
kicked to that.
You can.
Yeah,
that's a weird fucking.
Those guys went off into a kickboxing.
A lot of those guys.
Uh,
in the early days of kickbox,
a lot of those guys were killed.
Christian guys that learned a learn how to punch,
learn how to punch the face or not a box,
you know,
but they're kicks were extraordinary.
They would throw kicks from real weird angles because they were,
they were like standing rock 'em sock 'em robots style right in front of each
other sometimes.
And then throw those chopping.
Like,
I'm pretty sure our fate ptosis first style was,
uh,
was killed Christian.
A lot of those guys would throw that Brazilian kick.
That was like part of the style.
The Brazilian.
Okay.
One who was throwing axe kicks his feet Toso,
right?
No,
that was another guy.
It was like,
was it feel Francisco,
feel whole feel both of them glob safely Tosa and feel the
kicks landed in mma yet?
Not really.
We haven't seen that.
We've seen Allen Joel bonds throwing.
He's known for cartwheel kicks.
How crazy is that?
Yeah.
So was um,
uh,
what's his name?
Anthony Pettis.
The White Anderson Silva flux.
Brian Ebersol,
they would call him.
He,
it was just joking.
That was his nickname was two a dot m dot s dot gets ridiculous.
Was a silly dude.
He's a dude that he just retired
like a successful podcast,
right?
Sure son and Holy Shit Dude,
he is a murderer.
And if you heard his podcast is a great crushing,
smashes.
Perfect.
He's going to be the new Jim Rome.
He's so good.
It's perfect for just signs were a world series of fighting to play by play.
Good.
Look man,
like I can talk.
Son is one of the
top.
Conor mcgregor came along.
I said he was the greatest shit talker of all time,
but kind of took shit to another watch.
The ultimate fighter.
Oh Man.
Because his wicked with shit-talking.
Look at Josh Barnett.
Lean as fuck.
Trying to get that modeling contracts on.
Said fuck this.
Fuck.
He's been hanging out with Victor Webster too much.
Hasn't even been doing a lot of movies and movies.
A lot of acting and he's been doing some wrestling stuff in Japan.
Like the fake pro wrestling.
Don't say fake pro.
Sorry.
Customers in Japan right now.
There.
You're right.
I'm Josh Barnett.
Best.
Almost 40 to 61.
It says why?
Why?
No one's a hipster,
but hey.
Well why does it take to 61 that got it's tough on that belly.
Is it to 69 or [inaudible] 61.
It says one to me.
He probably took a giant shit and he came in and weighed himself again and he
was two 61
to 61.
Okay.
Ties off Bruce Buffer.
I was on his podcast.
That motherfucker can host.
Have you been on Bruce puffers?
Podcast?
I've been a natural host.
I was just.
I was shocked how good he was.
That guy is a professional house.
He's really,
really good.
We'll think about how good he is in route and announcer.
No one's better.
Never been a big difference between ring announcer and holding down a shovel.
He has no off button.
I've seen him in at restaurants in fucking Venice.
Who like Brendon and shop.
How you doing?
Just getting back from my karate lessons.
Bruce Buffer.
When we survey coming back from Abu Dhabi,
uh,
he hugged my ass up man.
He hooked me up,
man.
Bruce Buffer.
Leave a man.
It's a long story.
But he got me.
He used all his miles to get me a business class.
I had economy coming back from Sao Paulo,
man.
Yeah.
He was so cool.
He hooked it all up and like when you don't have to.
I,
I needed like 50,000 miles or something to do.
That shit was crazy and he hooked it up.
It.
That's so cool.
That's a,
that's a 15 hour flight Sao Paolo.
La Direct business class,
that was huge.
That was huge for the Rhonda fight.
I flew Rio to Sao Paulo,
Sao Paulo.
One way.
There's no one direct route from rail.
No,
no.
Direct flight to Rio.
You fly to Miami and then you fly to Rio or Atlanta.
You fly.
Yeah,
if I landed a Rio.
But uh,
Sao Paulo is a direct flight from La,
so I just went that way.
Do I feel like these guys have to fight each other for the retire right,
man.
Good fight.
This is going to be interested in such a fucking vet.
So as Roy Barnett thinks,
you know,
that he just has way too many tools and he fights too smart.
He thinks that Roy is just too one dimensional.
And it's interesting like that.
His approach to this fight was to get lean and to watch his diet,
whereas,
you know,
that's like counter completely counter to how Roy behaves.
Roy Roy is such an extreme fight,
man.
Yeah.
To hire an entire kitchen king,
pure fighters to vets.
Man.
What was Roy's last fight?
He,
his last fight was a fight.
He got knocked out by Mark Hunt and then you fight again after that.
Before that he fought.
No,
he hasn't fought.
Before that he knocked out no Gira and then before that he lost so he had a
giant,
giant victory over Nogueira,
which was crazy.
Huge.
That Abu Dhabi.
It was terrifying.
True.
It was just.
I never wanted to fight ever again after terrifying knockout,
but so then he lost a DC Frank Mir law got knocked up by Mark Hunt.
They're not fighting.
Mark Hunt one exposed like some holes in it.
Striking when you know Mark Hunt is just so slick and experience.
That's what I'm saying,
dude.
You got to be always careful of that shit.
Come on,
big boy.
I got thousand dollars against that entire mullet in that little hairball.
Eddie Bravo.
If you have your $2,000 in the hole,
you might have to rub his feet.
Do Somebody.
My cash is going to keep it rolling.
Now going back,
I'm getting a big kick by Barnett,
Josh.
It's the journey to zero.
The looking for the team.
Oh look,
he's trying to take it down.
Take some down.
Just look at these guys grapples.
Have we ever seen this?
Roy?
Roy Nelson taken someone down,
broke up.
What?
Did a work ain't on ultimate fighter.
He crucified people.
Roy's got his head against the cage.
It's heavy on top
of the fence.
If,
if,
if Josh,
pardon that gets tapped here,
you know,
God damn crazy that he's got the under hook on the wrong side here.
It's not as he's got an under.
It's got to like,
he's got the insight under hook on the time.
Just just smelling his back.
That's a good keywords for an arm bar against uh,
uh,
Ted Williams that if 10 years ago,
school man,
goddammit Ted,
remember Ted Williams got mad.
You always talk about how good the guard is.
Now.
Important to guard is,
oh dude,
that was an article on truck doing the garden on me.
Like,
well,
you're not the same size grappling,
grappling magazine.
He had an interview and it said the guard is dead.
He's the one who started.
He started the garden.
He needs a row at Verdugo and then revise that statement.
I'm sure it doesn't feel that or no revising statements from 15 years ago.
A lot of people had some ideas about what didn't work.
Dot Spinning kicks,
head kicks would never work and just like most people,
most of them see fans,
head kicks,
only working in movies and Ted Williams is right when he saw the state of the
guard that was in gladiator competent or king of the cage.
And you weren't seeing the best of the best.
Well you,
you'd have to be like almost at the Jujitsu competitions or in,
in the labs,
like why are they still rare to see a guard pass?
Why are they standing?
That's pure shit.
What is that?
Oh,
keep talking to Brian.
I keep throwing that left kick.
They want action,
Brendan.
Action.
It's just pushing them nasty ass please.
Oh,
you can't come straight in.
Line that against fucking Roy is going to come on Josh.
Come on Josh.
Hold Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
This is a free to get in trouble with his right hand.
John.
Oh,
nice opera.
That fucked Roy up.
It's got a tremendous team.
Has He ever been knocked out?
Mark Hudson walked away.
Josh Barnett is really pouring it on.
It's shown some excellent cardio here on this land.
That might've been his plan though in this fight to come and so lean just really
poor cardio or the pace on them.
It makes sense if you want to make a run for it.
Goodness,
that hurt.
Oh God.
Come on.
We'll think about if you bring it to zero.
Okay.
That sneaky uppercut bar netspend throw onto Josh was looking for that arm drag.
Josh,
you want to make a run at the title?
He got to cardio man.
Boom.
Big Knee.
Well,
you know what?
A man of a loss like that Travis Brown fight.
This guy's a warrior,
you know that lights a fire under a month.
They said he was fucking pissed.
Of course he was pissed when he came on my podcast.
He was talking about it.
He's mad about it.
Yeah,
well that Travis had done the film across the next thing.
He thought that was like super disrespectful and he said he just,
he wasn't up for that fight and you know,
I've heard,
I've heard all sorts of stories about Barnett's camp that fight.
We have a mutual trading partner and he said,
pardon?
It's campus pure shit.
So he's super upset about that man.
You know when a guy's been fighting for that long.
Yeah.
One guys been fighting for that long.
It's probably hard to get up like that for every camp,
but it takes him down.
He's winning.
This evolved.
He's evolved.
He never crashed down.
We'll never know.
He knows that it's trying to try and for that straight arm bar from his back do
you can tell he lost this railed roy money.
This is five rounds.
Oh Shit.
Which is bad for Roy.
One of five.
Yeah,
right here.
Watch.
He's going to go just to look at that nice life.
Oh,
Henzel Gracie.
Black belt son.
Yeah.
It's more like laundry room in black,
but he was with Mark Lehman longer than will henzel game as well as black.
But yes,
you're right.
You're right.
So mark claiming he did trade with her.
I agree.
Good ground and pound by Roy.
Good fucking ground and pound from the half Barnett off his back.
Interesting that he's able to take Barnett down one.
Do you think that like being leaner,
losing weight makes you a little more vulnerable takedowns because the guy
doesn't have to throw as much weight around.
Does that make any sense?
It does kind of make sense but only a little bit,
right a little bit because that's why there's weight divisions and wrestling
guys can take little guys down easy and those guys can take bigger deck guys
down.
He said,
I mean,
how much people are killing themselves.
The question is like how much of Barnett's weight loss is like he's lost some
fat clearly,
right?
To get down like 10.
What do you think is important in college?
How much lighter is 15 to 30 minutes to 64.
He lost 25 pounds.
Really 25 to 65 years.
Always weighed in for the Travis Browne fight was actually.
He was more like,
yeah,
about to 65.
But um,
so he lost some fat right now.
How did wrestle in college?
Josh Barnett?
Josh.
I don't think he did.
It was probably a junior college.
Um,
so I'm not that shocked that he's being taken down here.
It's not like he was a world class wrestler.
Dude.
No one takes josh down.
Really?
It's pretty rare.
But he's a DC to DC.
I think DC did.
Oh Shit.
Throwing haymakers get that money.
I'll send you a 50 percent buddy.
Dude.
Roy Nelson does not look like he's in bad shape here.
No,
don't let that get fool young
boy to God.
Dammit.
Roy has looking at voice,
throwing kicks.
He's got some.
Sun Is hurt.
Jesus Christ.
Roy Hits hard.
Joshua some big ass legs.
That's how.
So I got to go even gay because I would say there's some juicy thighs,
but a flat ass.
That's a bad luck on.
Hm.
This is interesting.
I remember hanging out with years ago,
never ever imagined he would be a UFC superstar.
Blocking people out.
I,
that's the last thing I ever would've imagined.
Dude.
We had breakfast with him at the,
the hotel in that little cafe before we ever had an mma fight and we knew him as
a Jujitsu guy.
He was a dude who was really good at Jujitsu.
Roy with four fights.
Oh Jesus.
He turned into a brawl.
Ooh,
good check.
Hooked by Josh to 48 to 48.
So he wasn't that much heavier for that fight.
He was only nine pounds heavier for you look like shit man.
His body looked like she's put on muscle mass fat,
but he definitely hasn't lost 25 pounds according to that when at least.
But he looks good,
man.
This is about as good fit.
He doesn't look week is what I'm saying.
So you're always taking them down.
I really don't think that that's the factor.
I think it's just Roy is catching them in transitions.
Oh Shit.
Straight left.
Fuck Bro.
Barnett boys are trading.
Barnett also looks like he's been.
He's been turned it on,
turned it on in this standup like that after initial Florida.
That was very good.
Beautiful Dude.
He's fucked up and he's pouring it on him.
Pull any switching south.
Paw Barnett's
Jesus,
boom.
Yeah,
and he's waiting for Roy to get tired before he pours it on to fighting crafty
in the beginning part of the Brown and then he hits around three minutes in.
He starts really turning it on.
Veterans Shit.
Yeah.
Well,
he also knows Roy Roy.
A lot of damage,
but trying to touch the ground.
You can't be at your best with that body.
There's no way.
Boom.
Yeah,
there's physically.
There's just girls like that,
but.
But let's go bro.
Let's say Roy,
let's say Roy gets down to 2:20 [inaudible].
Is he going to be this?
Is He gave me the same power puncher or is that right hand go away?
That's a super good question too.
Shit.
No one could know,
right?
You don't know until he tries it and he's never tried it.
I mean,
we,
we might see a better roy than ever.
Jesus Christ.
Josh is looking good.
He's relentless here with his standard is bleeding.
It's Josh.
His nose on a shoulder in agony means taking some big breaths.
Josh keeps hitting that solar plexus to.
Did you know when Josh would have a stitch corner on which this hurts?
I'm for sure not.
Haven't stitched.
Because you still only fight with stitch before we went.
Knocked on detail.
Stitch.
Let me die in there.
I still stitch the opposite.
Don't let me die.
And
I'd say stitch.
Look at me Bro.
Don't let me fucking die.
And there josh say the exact opposite.
Correct?
I remember thinking,
God damn,
that's gangster.
What's that?
Jamie was to 65 that fight.
Oh,
okay.
So boom.
So it was incorrect.
We're giving you a pallet.
Yeah,
you're 100 percent right.
Then that's 100 percent right?
More so.
Right.
Damn,
this is nasty.
It can be inserted.
This thing goes off five.
There's no way.
Damn.
I think it was a 26 pounds,
right?
And they said,
nope,
just 2:39.
So he lost 26 pounds.
That's insane.
Talking about dedication.
That elbow data.
Josh has mad that Reebok didn't make it.
Speedo Reebok.
Dennis hallman's pissed.
Oh yeah.
Josh,
you still is fighting those.
Boom.
There's that one again.
Oh Man.
His clenches nasty.
This fight.
I don't see how much hell Roy Roy has done.
He is tight as possible.
That's not possible.
Crazy.
Oh,
and Josh comes back as he's playing possum and he throws a head.
Fucking saw that head kick and rock them.
But then Barnett rock them back.
Is that his first head kick?
However,
I would assume so.
Especially in the UFC.
That was some straight panda bear shit,
man.
That tattoo he has on his shoulder,
that's his,
uh,
his.
He had a shirt,
a apparel line back when he was like a purple belt in Jujitsu.
Eight.
Oh,
eight or something like that or stuff like that.
That was like,
he was gonna make his money that way.
The skins.
He had dragon skins once that member that they're the rash guards.
He had like a really good brand of rash guards.
That was his.
I think that's it.
I think that's the local.
I think that's it because I,
I used to tell him he shot too.
He sent them to me once.
You had like the best rash card.
Really?
Yeah.
Just stopped doing them.
I don't know man.
You know,
that's a good question.
But he had rash cars was like a really good material that like wick sweat away
from you.
They were really good rash guards.
Roy's always
been a smart guy,
man.
He's always been on the outside of this tough texture.
It was soft,
but it was a tough texture.
And the idea I think was that it was really good for grappling.
[inaudible] wouldn't tear as easy as like,
it's cool a regular rash guard,
which has meant for surfing,
you know?
That's cool.
Yeah.
He's always been kind of the smart guy doing different shit.
He's always gone against the grain always.
That's been ryman.
So what happens now after that second round,
that second round was crazy.
It's one one.
Yeah.
But I.
There's no way.
This goes all five.
I think Burnett for boy hits him with one of those fucking head kicks.
What are we talking about?
If Roy landed that head kick and Barnett toes curled.
So we'd be like,
what?
In the greatest knockout in heavyweight history.
Here we go,
round three,
man.
Fuck man.
Both these guys are so fucking mentally tough.
You're not breaking either one of these.
Nice uppercut and he kicked me,
you know,
it's almost like Roy has to empty the gas tank early because he's got to try to
hurt Josh.
Wally.
Ken Too.
Those take downs or fresh.
He keeps get them down like this with a body of was trips.
Oh,
those knees are nasty.
Barnett's layman attempting to take him down.
I think that's interesting.
It is with Barnett's Fao heavy is on top.
While I think once a roy got on top of him to in that first round,
that was no fun.
No.
He said,
you know what?
Fuck this.
Roy's kind of respected game.
His,
his GRANDPA,
although we don't see it very often in his fights,
it's.
It's very high level.
Everybody knows it.
He's strong as fuck.
He's no joke.
These are good knees inside of the leg here.
I'm more impressed with Barnett.
Stand up.
How far it's come along in the clench.
Can tell he's working.
I'm only tie.
He does a lot of crazy shit to like.
Josh does savant and stuff like that.
He has like a savant trainer.
He's an interesting dude,
man.
Very smart guy.
Man.
Are you for or against male UFC fighters and wearing rash guards?
Will they let
they let the women would have guys wanted to.
Where would you be against that?
It's kind of girls wear long sleeve though.
I don't know a rash guards.
Right,
but would you be happy with just chest?
I would.
I mean I would think rash guards would mean like greasing obviously an MMA
pepperoni or accusing.
Anytime a fighter.
It's going to fight some guy that's known for Jujitsu.
If he doesn't grease up,
nobody's checking.
He'd be in a check now.
How do they check?
You get patted down.
What happens?
Here's the test.
Look at this.
Separated in separately to clench
down,
Bro.
That doesn't mean nothing.
Can't do anything.
If they give you a mineral oil bath the night before and then they wash oil
still there and no one's ever been.
The only way to really do it would be like after a fight they'd be a guy that's
assigned to that take the swab and doesn't like that across your back.
I don't think it's an epidemic.
I don't think it's like a huge issue.
I think
people are always complaining that people,
if you're going to fight a guy who's in St submission guy and
you know that you could take a mineral oil bath the night before and take a
shower and soap up the day after and it will still have an effect that won't be
measurable because like people are smoother and slicker after they do that.
Even after they take a shower.
When you play vaseline on fighters eyes that she gets all over the body,
touched the face,
grappling,
it gets on their back.
They all of a sudden the guy's full filled up with vaseline for sure.
Well remember when Anderson Silva wiped it off his face and wiped it on his
shoulders and his chest.
You know,
Clay Gregan choke.
His brother slap it on.
When he slap him,
he got in trouble.
We can't slap them anymore.
Yeah.
Is I think they should let fighters.
Were Reebok rash guards know how much money reebok with nick.
I don't think they'd make any more money than they're making with these shorts.
You know,
the fighters that I couldn't make reebok rash guards wouldn't be huge.
I don't know that in touch that market,
whereas when Pat Miletich fought Carlos Newton and Jeremy Horn like a,
I think,
I think it was that fight where he puts vaseline on on Pat's neck was one of the
fights where he put it out.
There was like a miscommunication and a bad idea to stanley.
Maybe a Jeremy fucked up.
I don't know who fucked up,
but there was somehow maybe Jeremy thought that Pat said put it on my neck.
I don't remember the details.
Oh Shit.
This fight.
It's crazy.
Running us her.
He just took a big deep breath looking for the single.
Oh,
if he gets them down another single leg,
look at this Roy Nelson.
Snap that leg straight.
That's exhausting for Roy by the way.
Yup.
But is it more exhausting than standing up and dealing with a barrage of strikes
that just keeps putting on him?
What kind of testing did they do in Japan?
So great point.
UFC tests.
Is the u s Ada doing it?
Who's doing it well are well.
Aren't the UFC fighters all tested randomly?
No.
That's what I think.
Right,
but.
But you got to,
it's September third is you have to fill out this sheet where you've got to give
them your location,
your whereabouts,
so they can come get you at anytime.
Right?
Um,
but like,
what is a,
I wonder how they're getting tested after this fight,
not doing roids anymore because of this,
that you think they're scared and they're like,
or what are they doing?
What do you think?
Shit,
what do you take them to get around this?
These new testing schedules?
Some of them for sure are going to stop doing it.
Some are 100 percent.
So,
you know,
it's always an issue though.
Wicki said that was pretty interesting.
He said they figured out a way to make testosterone from animals that's
undetectable.
Like now they can tell if it,
uh,
they make it from yams to make it from some wild Yam.
I don't know how the fuck they make.
And I was talking about micro dosing to kick to the body boom to the head.
Oh Shit.
What?
The Bolo Punches God damn.
What a fight.
What was that?
Around three?
That was around three.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
he was talking about microdosing,
but he was also talking about a new form
of testosterone that they've been able to do that they make out of animals.
I guess the test before could show that it didn't come from an animal,
that it came from some plant plant form.
The way they,
uh,
they create it.
So now apparently they're there.
They're able to do that.
We were also talking about the Tour de France.
What's so funny,
we laugh.
They had that band Europe taking the final countdown.
I can just imagine like their manager calling them and then say we've got some
good news,
national commercial,
good news.
The bad news is going to make fun of you.
They don't give a microwave.
Probably didn't know the managers.
They don't tell them until I get that.
And then they did in the middle of the commercial shoot and they kind of figured
it out.
Oh Shit.
They're goofing on.
You think they give a fuck dumb shit.
But it's still their song.
I mean,
they're still doing it.
It's not like national campaign.
Here we go round for a championship rounds.
What do you think that this is actually fought in a pretty fucking good pace.
Barnett with a high kick man.
Oh,
look at the body chapter.
Still got gas.
Look at him
pouring it onto
Barnett up three to one,
two to one.
If I was really absolutely doing practicing bitch,
I'm going to tagged back to zero.
I to zero as soon as it's over.
But when you think about the first round,
didn't Barnett do way more damage on the feet.
Taken down twice and dominated.
Didn't Barnett do more damage on the feet and he did it,
but it doesn't.
Does it?
No,
but it shouldn't matter.
Shouldn't matter.
Like who got hurt more in that first round?
I would say roy did.
I would say Josh did more damage standing up.
Oh
Man.
And a
great job.
If he didn't decide to go,
go for it right there.
He would've been on his back.
That was a fucking great guy.
Quick decision.
You got to keep going with that wizard.
Pam,
Josh Barnett.
It's just he's in better shape in this fight that I've seen him in a deal about
someone stomping on your feet as a dirty or is it part of the game
fighting part of the game?
No,
Josh Barnett tying his arm out punches to the body needs the body butter that
bright,
that entire bag of mangoes.
They're so good.
They're delicious.
Some of the best snack food ever.
Whoever figured out how to do that shit.
It was Jean Mexicans.
I know.
I put that online and that's all Mexicans kept saying,
okay,
he's Mexican.
We invented a lot of shit that we didn't get credit for.
All that Nwa Shit.
That's all Mexican low riders and Paula's the fucking outfits.
Stroke at all.
Oh Shit.
It's true.
Still.
People make fun of us.
Well,
it's just because we're so close to gangster rap.
Oh Shit.
Uppercuts.
Oh,
fucking tough.
Is Roy Nelson.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh my goodness.
Oh Shit.
Fuck bond.
Nasty elbows look to the Chin of Roy Nelson.
Oh my God.
It Barnett keeps mixing it up.
If Roy took him,
I mean if a partner took him down right now,
I was thinking be over Jesus company.
These elbow fucking punches the operate and the upper cut like shit.
Fuck.
Oh,
he doesn't know what's coming,
whether it's an elbow or an uppercut and Barnett just keeps changing it up.
It's weird how Roy national job,
he's doing such a professional job of mixing up this technique.
You know,
you still have his podcast.
No,
he doesn't do it anymore.
Nope.
Oh Great.
Yes.
I love having him on as a guest.
Super interesting.
Super Smart Man.
He's gonna.
Break his elbow.
Oh Shit.
And Roy comes back with an elbow his own again.
Josh Barnett is in crazy shape.
Josh,
this is Joshua for leg.
Does he roll down his style?
Catch wrestling?
Yeah.
He'll try to roll for a leg.
If he got his leg in between.
There we go.
But if he gets his leg in between them,
he will drop and roll.
Rolling,
man.
Look at this.
He's going for that Kimora.
Use it to stand up.
Look at that.
Can make steroid defend it and then stands up.
Goes to the defense,
turns around.
Smart man.
This is a great fight,
man.
It was a great fight.
No,
I'd love to see Barnett vs Arlovski.
That'd be really good at.
Around five is going to end right at three hours.
Okay.
Well just we'll restart it in between rounds.
We can't leave the people hanging here.
What if something crazy happens and we don't have it on film
after this round.
You have to start?
Yeah,
because we're at three hours because the fight is going over because I guess no
one thought that the fights would go that long,
but how would that possible?
Because our block.
Is that what they do and nothing's a stream or something,
but all the funds went to decision except for Uriah though,
right?
That's probably what it is.
Damn.
This is a great fight.
I like Josh to southpaw style too with that fucking left kick.
He keeps around.
Seems like Josh is definitely a factor.
Corsi is.
How could he not?
Roy is too though.
Look at both of them.
Josh had position position.
C'Mon.
That's exhausting.
It's exhausting.
Every time he's adjusting stays on.
It's hard to pull off a technique,
a counter technique when you've got someone's head up.
Tell you what,
man,
both these guys have been in there with just the best of the best thing about
Roy's fights in the UFC.
Yeah,
but if you think about experience wise,
wouldn't you give Barnett the edge seen on 100 percent went missing from his
resume.
Was fader true?
True.
But if,
if you,
if you go to UFC experience,
it's Roy far.
Yup.
What happened?
Did he hit him low?
Hit in the nuts.
Get that restaurant right at the bells.
At the end of the rail.
Wow.
Let's see this.
Oh Jesus.
I'm.
No,
that's the gut.
hold up.
Hold up.
Let's see if he gets.
This is just the beat down.
Jesus Christ.
These are awesome combinations.
There's a vicious uppercut bro.
You know who roy fought after he got knocked out by hunt over it.
Right to her leg lock.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
Right foot over him.
That was in last fight.
It was a good fight over him.
Had to stay the fuck away from him.
Yeah.
And Roy knocked him down once,
overcomes the jds next.
Correct.
What a fight that's going to be holy shit been for when you want to see overeem
versus Barnett.
I would love that.
That would be fucking interesting.
Super interesting.
That might be that fight.
I just think he's tougher.
I'd never find each other and pride her.
Nope.
That'll be a great fucking fight,
man.
I think Barnett [inaudible] Barnett Overeem,
there's a bunch of guys for fuck
heavyweight,
the easiest job to make fights jds and over him.
He's a great fight though and there.
There's been a lot of shit talking over the year and hate each other.
Huh?
Yeah.
I wonder,
uh,
I mean it's a good time because over Ian's got some confidence now.
I think so.
I don't think so.
Well,
I think so because jds has had some trouble.
It's a good time for the body by Barnett.
I think it's a good time for overeem.
It's bad for JDF.
That's what I mean.
And I think that if it was earlier,
it would have been a good time for jds and a bad time for ovary.
I agree.
Josh Barnett pouring it on.
I agree 100.
So I think like right now though is like the closest it's been,
you know,
I think I would have given overeem and edge if you would have the overeem that
fought brock,
that motherfucker over the world.
That's the only fight ever in my life.
They would have called me.
I'm like,
no good man.
Not Interested.
Nom hurt.
What he got?
I don't know.
Make something on that.
Yo Stop feeling that overeem the 265 pounds shredded overeem regardless of
substances that enhance that position.
That motherfucker was terrifying.
So that guy,
I like him over,
uh,
a lot of people maybe even over junior dos Santos,
but bro,
I like Kim over judo.
Sentos and cane at the same time.
Fuck,
that guy was on another note.
I don't know though.
I don't know if he will be able to do that to Cain in that fight.
I mean,
what would he have been able to keep?
What you got to think?
First of all,
we're looking at their results,
but we're not thinking about the players because Josh,
I mean I'm A.
Brock Lesnar was coming off a stomach surgery,
I don't know,
12 inches on the homeland.
Robert was touching him and just fuck it.
Looked like it hurt.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
overeem's terrifying.
There's no doubt about this.
This new room is not as terrifying.
Well,
it's not the same guy,
you know?
I mean physically,
no,
not even close,
but we don't know how much of that fight was over him and how much of it was.
Brock lesnar really should have been fighting.
I agree.
What,
what MMA legend.
You have surgeon did a valentine over and beat randy couture.
Huh?
Hold up.
He beat a Valentine beat.
Her.
Joe Said,
don't act like you're just,
you're just said red.
He gets named Randy cookie tapped,
but he never fought in the UFC.
He also beat Ray Sefo,
which is old school,
but he got him in a neck.
Right,
right.
But raise more of a [inaudible] legend that he is a UFC legend.
Right?
Yeah.
Last time I'm fine
with it.
It's that
whole,
uh,
ensign.
Anyway.
Arm barred.
Randy,
remember that fight incident kicked randy with some crazy hard kicks off of his
side.
Like he was like lying on his side,
like in a,
almost like a semi.
Hoists doesn't Sakharova to stone's office back some serious kicks.
The grandma's knee.
Yeah.
Fifth and final reading.
He does have a more,
but he doesn't have the legs.
Right.
And that's Roy Nelson.
That promoter is not going to be shit.
It's going to be hard to josh by Nick.
Um,
um,
but it was like on a side thrown roundhouse kick to the leg.
Fucking hard kicks man.
Like I remember thinking like,
Whoa,
I didn't know you could throw kicks like that from your side.
Like that's first time I've seen a guy do that.
Oh Shit Roy.
Not much time left.
Oh,
nasty.
Needed the body.
How about randy couture set of Bell Toro to sign fate?
Or He'd want to still fight him.
Did he really say that?
How old is randy doesn't.
He said he was interested in that fight.
Well,
if he's interested,
we don't know who fader is fighting in Japan.
If Japan really wants to make some money that's filed is randy couture that 50
to 50 2:52.
Hey Man,
let's not do that.
Huh?
How about that?
I'm all for it.
Fuck no,
I would.
Let's make $50 a new Ford Kimbo slice and make sure that randy couture is 52.
Could you,
could you look that up?
Bob Sapp.
Medowra nosy.
What if it's whatever they kimbo fade or horrendous.
Horrendous.
You mean awesome.
No Man,
there'll be so wrong.
Dude.
That'd be so fucked up.
A juiced up Faye door.
Maybe 50 something right.
Ken.
Shamrock shredded.
But if someone comes back and he's at his old skill level,
that's a terrible mismatch.
I mean that's a big if bro.
Well,
if they're letting them fight in Japan,
if Japan doesn't have any,
we're not saying I just want to get right out of the way.
Don't accuse me of accusing him of juicing,
but let's just say.
Let's just say we go back to the vandelay.
Kelly's Roy.
Go for
it.
Going for it.
He is going for it.
Fuck it.
Fifteen seconds.
Oh Shit.
Nice Combo.
Josh looked up at the clock 12 seconds ago.
Oh,
it was a hard shot to the forearm.
A side kick.
Damn shot.
What a fucking fight and fight.
Dan.
Did we make it out of three hours?
We're always three.
Whatever.
Other trucker a Barnett by decision,
right?
So most likely never to.
I bet they give to them three to never know.
I mean,
we've seen crazier shit take downs in Japan.
You can.
You never know.
Boom,
boom.
What a great fight.
I'll tell you one thing.
Unquestionably,
Josh Barnett looked as good as he's ever looked like.
His,
his physical shape,
like the combination is the best one.
Was the tune a long time.
Roy was way more prepared than his body would let you think.
Right?
I mean he obviously went five,
never judged by her,
hurt them in the fifth round.
You know,
he still had power in the fifth and final round.
Come down four times.
It took them 10 times and took him down to fifth and hurt him in the fifth to
banged them.
I think he hates him.
Hard fucking kicks to his arms to match.
So a guy like Roy,
he's won one his last five.
What do you do with that?
Never let that guy go.
He's always fun.
He's always fun to watch,
man.
Can't let that guy go.
No,
I'm saying if your Roy Roy is hard.
What do you do?
You know,
honestly,
what he needs to do is what Josh just showed he needs to get in some serious
defining themselves.
Will take some time off.
Well,
yeah,
get me.
Look how much better Josh looked with a Dietitian.
I mean,
I guess it's a guy who trains with.
Is a guy who's a prescribed as diet for him who's monitoring has died for him.
But look how God Damn Goodie look.
Five hard rounds.
I guess I'll bomber like Roy Nelson.
Scrap scrap.
Yes.
And Josh looked great in the fifth and final round.
They still had real good.
They both looked amazing.
Pouring it on at the end.
Sure as fuck was.
But now let's imagine if Roy had done the same thing that Josh did.
Would Roy won that fight?
Who knows,
man,
if Roy had did the same thing that Josh Day as far as monitoring his diet,
but it could still hit that fucking hard and lost the body fat,
had more gas in his tank,
was able to pour it on more will disable the counter more off the cage.
The difference in this really wasn't really striking was that it was this
takedowns.
His grappling.
I was,
let's say he loses weight so there's taking pitches down and not losing the
position because of scrambled eggs like,
you know,
not,
not conserving his gas tank.
Tremendous shape.
Let's say.
Let's say he got down to one 85.
Can you imagine how good his Jujitsu would look?
Oh my God.
Incredible.
I mean,
who knows?
One 85.
We were kind of talking crazy.
We really want to lose 85 pounds.
You're talking about a different case.
He's a big guy.
Jujitsu too heavy.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's his gate
on the how light it could be,
but what?
What?
Could it be happening gentlemen?
Come on man.
Look at that.
No,
no man.
You might be wrong though,
because look,
what if he loses 50 pounds?
Okay.
If you this your man's just to 10.
If he loses to townies,
Chris Weidman,
and then he gets.
Yeah.
And then you think about that all sound fun that you want to bet 10 g's.
Boy never gets some when 85 tens years.
Josh Barnett.
Warm master.
Congratulations.
He's not even breathing heavy.
Well,
I mean he's tired for sure.
It's a hell of a fucking hell of a fight.
She's a hell of a fight.
God Damn Josh Barnett.
Let me see if you say some crazy progress on shit.
Crank that shit up because sometimes he says crazy progress and show usually.
Good boy.
He picked me up once.
I felt like a pillow after the fight.
He was still jazzed up after the,
uh,
Frank Mir fight.
He hoisted me up in the air like a throat,
like a star.
Like a welcome mat was welcoming.
But I felt like Josh should have said Satanic Tattoo.
It's going to talk in Japanese.
He talks Japanese.
That's where the money comes in.
They love him over there,
man.
Japanese man.
What a style is getting big laughs.
Good,
good,
isn't it?
So you're going to be such an unusual dude.
Yeah.
He's a weird guy.
I respect the fuck out of that guy though.
I'm am not going to hang out with them,
but for sure you wouldn't hang out with him.
I probably would.
We're just so different,
man.
You would love him.
Really?
Yeah.
He's awesome.
I'm a big fan of Josh Barnett as a person.
I like hanging out with them.
I love having him on the podcast.
He's great on your podcast.
Smart motherfucker.
Dude.
As smart and as well read and as you know,
is nuanced in his thinking as a,
as anybody I know.
And he's a professional fighter at the highest level.
Nothing I didn't hear.
It was good enough that I.
Nothing
I did in here was good enough tonight.
He's a fucking monster.
Oh,
he's on a fucking bender right now.
Or that's not the right word.
Bender vendors for drinking.
Yeah,
he's on a run is what I meant to say.
he's doing well.
That's what I like to say.
He's not a real bender,
ladies and gentlemen,
Mouth Insert foot.
It would be one thing if I didn't do this.
He's looking at Josh Barnett.
Oh my God.
Are you looking at eyes and said
he's like Godzilla fro,
you know,
rampage destroys in Japan.
Deal Destroys Asians in America.
How dare you bring it up.
Holly's not here to defend himself.
He likes,
you know,
they're talking about having rampage fight rumble.
Why would they do that?
Have you heard Shogun?
I liked that.
Or is Dan Shogun?
It's Dan Shogun.
Shogun just had shoulder surgery.
He's been in a sling,
like his arm has been a back training as he was in a sling like really recently.
Really?
Like really recently there was photos of him I think on instagram or something
like that of him in a sling.
I read Shogun.
That's what I heard.
I'd be crazy for the next fight.
That's a crazy fight.
But if shogun did have shoulder surgery,
I don't know what surgery had or why rampage I,
you know,
I might be making this up because I'm assuming it was a shoulder thing because
he had his arm in a sling.
He have just,
it could've been something as simple as like bone spurs in his elbow,
which is a quick turnaround.
A lot of guys do.
What does he say?
Surgery.
What does it say?
Early 2016 return.
Yeah.
So it's probably shoulder.
What does it say?
Does it say what kind of shirt show what kind of surgery?
Young Jamie Shoulder.
Shoulder,
shoulder surgery.
See Shit.
No,
I just,
I did.
I did hear shogun rampage.
Well,
so from a reliable source,
well now shogun is not gonna be able to fight until 2016.
I wonder what they'll do because.
Well,
you know what?
Last blight crime,
Sun.
But most of the fights up until December already accounted for anyway.
Especially the big end of January already accounted for anyway.
So maybe that is the fight,
but rumble,
rumble versus rampage will be crazy for as long as it lasts.
That's a crazy fight.
What a rampage winds.
Rampage can take it.
And
I love rampage that I don't like that fight for him.
Scary fight.
Rumble.
Fine right now.
Fucking to find out.
How good did he look?
He's
terrifying.
That Gustafson fight.
Scared the fucking shit out of me.
Well then he knocked fucking homeboy to next week,
dude.
He's a monster.
Straight Monster.
Yeah.
He's so good right now.
And you know what I think is coming off of that Daniel cormier a loss.
He's upset with himself and trade and even harder,
even more focused tool.
It's really wide open.
So grabbing a whole shit load of pictures of his dog.
So the dogs,
you know,
he's taking it serious.
What does that mean?
What proves that he's,
he's,
uh,
an emotional person in the.
Any.
His heart is in the right place because he instagram pics of his dogs.
Yes.
It's weird,
man.
Got Interesting.
Take on it.
Know it bothers me when guys post quotes all the time.
Well,
aren't those guys or girl post quoted
to stop following the Frank [inaudible]?
He kept posting quotes.
Frank,
who?
I said a friend.
Oh,
I'm not going to blast.
What kind of quotes are you talking about?
What?
Like be strong and follow your um,
all that shit.
The light.
Successful people don't hate on others.
Just bullshit like that.
You know,
it's going to funny bit about like motivational dudes.
Online's Leah.
It's pretty fucking funny man.
It's crystally.
It doesn't work out at all.
And he's got like this,
uh,
this is really funny bit about guys who are telling you like,
I think it says like Hashtag,
Hashtag eat a dick,
see my shoes.
I'm so,
so these beast mode shoes.
And he wrote on there like,
those fucking suck.
Then sent me a text.
I was like,
why don't you go fuck yourself?
I put,
Hey man,
I love,
I can design them.
It's fun to say Hashtag something,
a lot of community and say that other Hashtag suck it hashtags.
People say that all.
I could catch myself doing it too.
It's like a really funny thing that people are doing crazy is when I hashtagged
the things.
When I posted a meme,
I can see like people,
I could see my uh,
followers rise.
But when I post anything like anti vaccine or any Kinda dude,
hundreds,
72,000,
point eight,
and then it goes point seven,
point six,
two.
They don't like conspiracy.
So many followers to line 1111.
I lost.
You know what?
I cleaned them out.
It's a filter.
I to clean those fuckers out.
Whatever.
I try to watch a video of tower seven go down and free fall speed
follows nine slash 11.
Hey,
I'm cleaning them out
to go to the comedy store.
So we gotta we gotta wrap this show.
We got to wrap this bitch up.
Chem trails,
seven
flying rods.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Eddie Bravo.
This was awesome.
Thank you sir.
I begin lucrative tee shirts now available@higherprimate.com.
November twelfth live.
Find the kid,
Tempe,
Arizona.
800 tickets left.
That's it.
And uh,
there's one that sold out in Ontario in October first.
And I might be a part of that mother
this Thursday.
I'm in 10th.
Tenth Planet Indianapolis this Saturday.
And I just uploaded Ebi for,
for free on youtube.
Eddie Bravo.
Invitational for in its entirety.
Free on youtube.
Check it out.
Thanks everybody for tuning in to these things and thanks for indulging us in
this ridiculousness and we'll see you soon.
Next week with some real podcasts.
The real one though.